each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available hey everybody I think it's
about time we get started um so thanks
again for making it this morning
hopefully the rest of the stragglers
will come in soon um I think maybe just
one announcement so uh Nate kushman
suggested we put up this sort of
resources uh Google spreadsheet that's
updatable during the course of the
worksheet that's available at the top of
the website and you'll you may have to
hit refresh a couple times to get past
your dirty cashed copies or something so
feel free to jump in there and add some
resources we're also going to broaden it
a little bit so if there are topics or
collaborations that you'd like to bring
up during that final session like areas
you think we should focus on please just
add some of those suggestions so we can
address them and um see how people might
want to be working together either
through data or resources or just in
general problem spaces yes saying maybe
we should just send the link out again
or put it up on the slides or write on
the Blackboard or something yeah okay I
will do something maybe just email it
yeah I'll email it to everybody
apologies for the spam um so with that
announcement let's get started with the
first session thanks I'll let Dennis and
Donna take care of
it uh thank you very much so let's get
started this is information retrieval
and soft engineering uh session and
Donna and I will will chair the session
so the idea uh for the session first
we're going to have elevation talk for
20 30 minutes uh feel free to ask
questions uh in the um in between and
then we really want to push the
discussion uh for for the session we'll
have approximately one hour for that so
uh our uh elevation talk will be given
by andrean Marcus who is associate
professor of computer science at the
University of Texas Dallas uh he has
been working um on information retrial
for quite a few years by now um
published many papers graduated some
students so um um and he will give us um
overview of the field and hopefully it
will help us to jump start the
discussion okay um thank you Dennis you
can hear me all right um um all right
since I didn't have my minute yesterday
to two minutes to introduce myself I go
by Andy marks I'm at associate professor
at UT Dallas and yes as Denny said we've
been using Tex and sof Jing for over 15
years uh actually it was a topic of my
disertation and uh starting with my
disertation and uh two of my students
are in the room Sonia there and Dennis
former students and Dennis's former
student Colin is here so between us and
two of other Dennis students who are not
here we had actually six PhD
dissertation the last 15 years all using
text retrieval one way or another in
software engineering published over 100
papers so there there's a little bit of
Rich history so all of these indiv some
of these people are here right you've
seen Dennis Sonia Colin is Dennis's
former student Martin's current student
and Vin was doing a post talk earlier
with me she's now at um um Washington
State
University um so uh what sort of work we
have done um in uh using text and
software engineering well I think over
the last 15 years we end up addressing
12 different suffring problems ranging
from bug localization traceability link
recovery that uh we heard talk about
yesterday and Jane mentioned clone
detection again people mention clone
detection yesterday reverse engineering
not so much discussed yesterday coupling
cohesion measurement and refactoring
again not a lot discussed yesterday
defect prediction ta talked about it in
his uh um tutorial coot ization somebody
mentioned a little bit yesterday but not
much B Tri was talked about yesterday
query formulation uh text retrieval
model configuration and the API
retrievals that was discussed yesterday
so um this is the these are things we
have addressed in the last 15 years but
for this talk I don't want to talk about
our work I am going to talk about what
has been done in this area um so I'm
going to give a very short history of
text software engineering I will
overview the main software engineering
tasks and how we formulate how we
address them with text retrieval and
when I say we I mean the community at
large and uh I will highlight challenges
so every every time you see some orange
color on the slide it's a challenge that
currently as far as I I consider it
exists in the field okay and some of
these challenges are going to be task
specific some of them are cross cutting
right U okay so here's the very short
history of text retrieval and Sofer and
drink so I'm glad uh we have this
Workshop today um well these days and
it's a lot of um discussion mostly on
language models but we have been
handling text in software for a long
time I wish we had a workshop like this
10 or 15 years ago we didn't but still
we didn't work in a vacuum so just so
you know back in the late 80s early '90s
there was a handful of individual
um yel m i remember Bill Frakes and in
Somerville who actually used text
retrieval to index software libraries
and they published in the software use
conferences and C there was actually a
track at C on reuse back then and then
there was nothing for a decade and Circa
1999 and um uh yesterday Jane alluded
that it a group of Italians started
working on traceability they still do
today it's a unsolved problem and then
uh 2000 is actually when I started
working on it and and several other
people and we started addressing other
selft ranging tasks uh and there was a
little bit of community building
happening slowly but it was inside
software engineering um I don't recall
ever seeing anyone from NLP or texal
Community we do have some crossover um
uh don is over there actually she worked
on organizing some of these Workshop
naturalize uh this one right uh yeah so
back in in in ' 06 uh Dennis actually
organized we with Dennis we organized a
a working session at icsm that would be
the software maintenance conference for
those outside the field uh then there
was a little bit of a gap uh until the
field picked up critical mass and we
have several workshops in the last few
years some of them with NSF
funding um actually one of them in
particular it's at its fifth edition
this year it's called Mud uh Sony there
was the organizer this year actually
Dennis gave a keynote over there um so
so there was a community building but
um as I said to my knowledge and correct
me those of you who are in the room and
know there I'm aware of only two pairs
of researchers that managed to Crosscut
between text retrial and software
engineering one of them is in the room
Don L who's original text Roper IR
person and she's working with Dave
Binkley for 10 years now more and the
other one is VJ Shanker at Delaware
who's working with Lori pollok she being
the software engineer VJ Shanker being
the
NLP that's pretty much it these are the
only uh pairings across fields that sort
of uh stood the test of time there were
other maybe individual efforts small
ones like but these are the only ones um
in terms of production the field this a
little bit outdated these are papers we
we tried to do a survey a few years ago
and it was turned out to be too daunting
of a test
um that's 2012 but the trend continued
like that so in the last decade in
software engineering actually they have
been published uh nearly 500 papers on
using text retrieval in software
engineering it's a big field by now
right um
so however since we didn't have this
sort of event to to be able to be
introspective that's why I'm happy
what's going on here right because we
we're sitting down asking the questions
we have language model what can we use
them how what's the best way to use them
right we really didn't have that um back
in these days right so the community as
far as I can tell instead took a more of
a uh applied approach let's see what
problems in software engineering we can
solve with text retrial the question
wasn't at that point which is the best
text retrieval model for the problem
what can we solve with text retrial and
as it turns out it's um uh by my count
30 30 some difference sof ringing
problems were and are being addressed
with text retrieval today and many
people in this room are doing that all
right so how did the community do
that well from what I can tell there are
two approaches for most uh um two ways
to use text retrieval in software enging
option one is formulate the softw enging
task as a text retrieval problem and
option two is formulate the soft ranging
task as a text analysis problem and I'll
explain the differences and give an
example of each and highlight the
challenges that happens each time so
everybody knows what a text retrieval
problem right you build a corpus index
it formulate the query retrieve the
results and and you know go back and
reformulate the query of what happens so
really this is it so you pick the
software engineering problem and you
have to decide uh what you're going to
build uh your Corpus from and how and
how you're going to get your queries uh
compute similarities and so on and so
forth what sort of tasks are addressed
this way okay U classic one probably two
of the most research ones would be
anything related to concept feature
location bug localizations those are
related problems traceability link
recovery but there's several other ones
reuse probably it's third in terms of
volume of uh interest right
option number two well the first two
steps are the same as before you still
need to B build a corpus from some
software artifact you still need to
index them with some sort of text
retrieval model but past that point it's
not a query based uh issue instead you
compute similarities between every
document in your Corpus and then you use
these similarities to Define some
measures and metrics that reflect
properties of the corpor that these uh
uh this information captures and then
you use that uh uh those measures per uh
to perform the text analysis I'm talking
about so what kind of problems uh we
address that way um well anything from
software categorization to refactoring
reverse engineering B triage defect
prediction and so on and so forth so let
me give you some examples by the way
feel free to interrupt me I'm going a
little bit fast so I leave more time for
discussion but um feel free to interrupt
me so uh how do we Define a pro a soft
ranging task as a text retriever problem
first we need to this uh Define the
context of the task uh those of us who
worked in the field we know that text
retrieval only gets you T that far it
will not solve the
problem right you have to use something
else typically it solves a sub problem
or a sub task you have to Define it to
see which part of the bigger task is
really helped by text retrieval you have
to Define your input and output that
determines your choice of Corpus later
on what information need you have as I
said typically for almost everything we
do in Source related to software we need
more than just text we need structure we
need Behavior we need process
information um from a researcher stand
up point of view we need to Define
evaluation right if you want to make
progress in the field we need very well
Define evaluation criteria and remember
we're typically solving a sub problem of
a bigger one okay and then uh um you
remember I listed a dozen soft ranging
problems pH phrased as text retrieval
problems there are differences between
them right and and going back 10 years
ago I remember reading many of reviews
like how is this different than uh
traceability or how is this different
than bog localization right because at
the core every one of those papers was a
text retrieval
problem so you have to make sure you
specify
that okay uh then once you you once you
define your problem very clearly this is
the one I'm phrasing as a text retrieval
problem well you have to instantiate it
yes sir so I'm um um finding the
discussion um a little generic so I'm
wondering if if there could be some
concrete example I I have a concrete
example okay yes yes yes I'll remember
all this abstractly and then when you
instantiate yes yeah exactly so I I have
one example of one test where every one
of these steps I I I explain how we how
people do it yes but it's still the
steps so okay yeah um and yes I only
have one example but then we have an
hour of discussion so I I was bound to
20 minutes by the chair so now it's 22
because of Soul Okay so
uh um anyway so so once we Define this
problem and all those parameters I
mentioned um well it it it we want to
instantiate it as a text retrieval
problem now so we need to Define what
goes in the Corpus what's the document
granularity is the question here how do
you normalize your text then you need to
index it and here's the question you
have is which text retal model I'm going
to use at and what
parameters um then I have to queries
right and the question is where do those
queries come from how are being
formulated or
reformulated um then as I said typically
uh any results will be combined with
some sort of other information from
software be that static or dynamic
analysis results and of course then you
you worry about how you show the results
to the consumer which is typically a
programmer okay so here's an example
okay the task I'm I'm focusing on I
picked it because uh
we worked a lot of it but that's we're
not the only ones obviously as I said um
concept location is software it's an
instance of the concept assignment
problem um in in the in the realm of
software it's essentially defined
Loosely as locating the implementation
of a concept in the code okay now this
is just as generic if I said do that
like it's a problem where does the
implementation start and where does it
end they're not Chris Brown iies you
know uh there audities of the
programming language the main function
is that part of all Concepts or no
concept right uh these are very tricky
decisions so you need to to make those
steps that I'm going to go through in a
minute to instantiate this in in your
context right and there are other
instances of the same problem with the
concept assignment feature location bug
localization traceability link recovery
and I will explain at the end what are
the differences at least some of the
differences all right so here are the
steps we you need to pick up a concept
why do you need concept location for or
context sorry why do you need concept
location for at least in our research
and typically in the research of vast
majority of the community is software
change right um and what's the software
change it's you know you define a
process for it typically starts with a
change request call it anything you want
it's change request um and and and it's
succeeded by impact analysis so in this
context concept location starts with the
change request that's your
input and the output is is the location
in the code where you will start the
change not the entire change not the
whole implementation that's the job of
impact analysis to take care of right so
it's very very narrowly defined very
well well uh what sort of other
information needs we need on we
obviously here is text everything what
I'm talking about it's about leveraging
text right because change request is
natural language most of it most of of
them output is in Co location and code
though okay but we typically to solve
the entire problem the entire problem of
software change we also need code
structure behavior and often times uh
process information right but for the
sake of retrieval you do not necessarily
need that however you want to bring them
in okay so how do you evaluate what are
the criteria and the
methodology um as with any text
retrieval problem remember we just
phrased concept location like that you
typically use what precision and recall
I don't think I have to Define it here
in this room and you need some sort of
goal set now how do we Define goal sets
um in concept location related to
software change well one technique
that's today is popular but uh is to
reenact change and simulate user
Behavior what does that mean everybody's
familiar with historical re enactment
right you know that Napoleon's Army and
whatever Wellington's army were in this
position at the beginning and you know
what was the end but you don't really
know exactly what happened in the middle
who killed who at what time right it's
the same here we can look at historical
data we know that you got this bug
request or change request and you know
when you committed when you committed
the patch what exactly change we don't
know how you changed it but I know the
input so we built go goal sets based on
that right uh we have um uh issue
description and then we have patches now
one problem one challenge is is is the
correctness of those patches right rvan
you mentioned yesterday you did bug
localizations how many uh bug
descriptions and patches have you used
what was your data set uh
ecse right order of magnitude did you
check manually check all the patches
thousand right thousands right but did
how many of those you check manually no
you see so we have a problem this is
still a challenge in the field there's
very little curated data out there right
uh so we don't know whether those
patches are actually fixes to the box or
uh contain other commits as well right
it's a problem so it's very hard to do
we have very little city data and then
you simulate their user and this is a
little bit of a problem so
um a text retrieval technique will
return your rank list of documents right
in our case uh we have an issue
description as a query and we get pieces
of code return as documents right now
how do you evaluate uh here well we
assume in a Ideal World that the user
would go through that rank list one by
one now we all know that in reality
that's not true but all things equal you
throw two techniques at the same data
and you assume that whoever ranks
something High or FAS you know it's
better so we we do this assumption right
also in the case of change that's a
that's a proxy for effort it took you
how much code you had to look at right
um in reality what happens and we know
there's data and studies about that
people actually uh do go to rank list
but they also follow dependencies and so
on and so forth so it's a much more
complicated model on of how people uh
look at results at code in general en
regardless of what code returns it
okay
um one of the common measure here and
there will be people in the room
objecting to that uh to measure the
effectiveness of a of a uh retrieval
tool in this particular context is the
rank of the first changed piece of code
okay as I said the reason people adopted
that and I'm one of the adopters of that
is because it's an estimate
of human effort now if you pick up
random paper from those several hundreds
I mentioned people will use map and mrr
that that would be mean average
precision and mean reciprocal rank uh
there is no
consensus oh hits at one hits at five
there's all sorts of measuring all sorts
of papers and uh there are very very few
papers actually justifying why I picked
that measure typically the justification
is well this other paper that was
published 6 months ago used it so I use
it too and I show my tool is better um
this is something we as a community have
to decide which way to go now um ideal
way to do evaluation of concept location
would be user
studies very rare I'm aware of again um
we started working on this in 2004 so
that's 11 years by now I'm aware of
about three or four user studies in 11
years
um why they're challenging there's
always learning effect if I have a
somebody change something on the code uh
with using some tools and then second
times without there is learning effect
uh every textbook on on running user
studies tells you that when there's a
significant learning effect you may not
want to do it it's very hard to control
it very hard to control confounding
factors right experience you name it uh
it's very costly we all know that and um
um our community the software
engineering community no offense to all
of us are insufficiently still educated
on how to do this right a we don't know
how to do it right or perfectly rather
and as opposed to let's say psychologist
they do that from day one we don't we
don't do that and uh the reviewers don't
they complain all the time you only use
students and so on and so forth right so
we don't even have a notion of
representative sample so this is very
difficult okay now that's the definition
of concept location in terms of context
input output evaluation information need
now how do we instantiate as a text
retrieval
problem what's the document okay
typically it's concept location in
source code so the Corpus is built from
the source code that's the easy one
second document
granularity how many of you in this room
used uh did research related to this and
used Class level
granularity all right 1 2 3 4 5 six
hints how many of you use method level
granularity okay how many of you use
five level
granularity okay I rest my
case uh typically we do it
opportunistically uh you know my tools
cannot parse methods so I'll use file
that's that's the state-ofthe-art right
hundreds of papers later right uh what
text retrieval method uh should we use
for the problem as I said I I'm putting
words in everybody's mouth here but our
Drive was let's see the problems we can
solve not so much as match the best
model to the best problem um to my
knowledge these are the most popular
that have been used feel free to add to
the list those of you who list um you
know um many of us tried several you
know often many people just publish
paper running on the same data four of
these and concluded that this one's
better and as I said the data was not
probably curated propably curated and so
on and so forth so we have a problem
that are challenge for sure query how do
we formulate query well in concept
location typically it's manual but you
can uh uh use the issue report uh to
extract information from it or you can
copy paste it if you wish and the
typical way to reformulate car is to
relevance feedback right um combination
with additional information this has
been a lot of work on this um and uh
typically um dependence static
information something like a dependence
graph or dynamic information something
like an execution trace or uh I forgot
to add there information uh from process
like previous authorship and uh code
changes historical code changes are
being added to it um how are the results
presented typically like code signatures
linked to the code however this issues
spawn off uh uh soof field uh recently
in uh this area of code summarization it
actually came out of this what should we
show to the developers as results right
okay now different es from other
instances this is one of the issue like
what's the difference between concept
location as I just described it and
feature location bug localization
traceability link recovery the
differences are actually a little bit
subtle right and it has to do with how
you have feature location this is
critical features in a software are
subset of Concepts there are Concepts
associated with visible functionality
what does that mean I can define a
scenario to ex exercise that feature
right think about if if the concept I'm
looking for it's a link list in the code
there's no execution scenarios that
guarantees me executing you know finding
a link list but for features it is so
this is a big difference right you can
use in this instance execution traces
and actually is desirable and one of
Dennis's contribution in his PhD was
that once you combine uh uh execution
traces with text retrieval the results
are orders of magnitudes better right
um so this is one of the major
differences not else right this is just
a feature location is a subset of
concept bog localization right some
people mentioned here working on that
bog localization well this is very
typical this time you you have to start
from a bug report right uh and if it's
automatic that implies you use the
entire uh bug description right again
you might have execution traces or stack
traces there uh you might combine it
with test cases in this case or anything
else that it's in the book description
anything else around it past authorship
code changes and so on and so forth
something you don't necessarily have in
in like pure concept location and of
course you you can and typically do
automate query formulation three subit
link recovery it's a little bit
different um this time the trace the the
queries are fixed right you go from
let's say uh a use case Cas number seven
to the code well use case number seven
is your query you're not going to change
it are you whereas here there is a lot
of changing
queries um okay so typically there's no
uh query reformulation now something I
didn't mention before traceability
recall is I argue it's more important
than Precision this changes the game in
in in concept location I told you you
care about finding the place of change
as soon as possible that means I I I
sacrifice Reco for precision if I got
the that that guilty method on position
one I don't care about recall because
that's what I'm looking for traceability
recall is important especially uh right
Jane was talking about yesterday about
tracing regulatory code I want to make
sure that all the places in the code
where that is taken care of I'll
find right so this immediately leads to
two different research strategies you
know those of you who worked in Tex well
you know that if you try to improve your
Precision it will cost in terms of
recall and vice
versa all right so that's the example of
concept location I hope it's specific
enough um and I have a shorter one about
the other kind of uh um problem so um
here's for example again this comes from
Dennis's dissertation work 10 years ago
oh you're getting old uh so um we
defined um uh a new cohesion metric
using text retrieval for software and
it's inspired from discourse
analysis right uh this was one of those
uh uh in other words uh uh coherence
measurement in discourse analysis right
um and you do the same you uh index the
source code you pick your text retrieval
model and we compute textual similarity
between every single method in the
system and then you take classes and and
you do some sort of of averaging of
those similarities to reflect cohesion
right
um this is 10 year this is you know
almost 10 years before the word
naturalness came to scene right but we
were thinking that there's an analogy
between natural language discourse and
software discourse and if we can measure
the coherence of one we should be
measuring be able to measure an
equivalent notion of the other one which
in our case is cohesion
so Dennis worked at the time like okay
are we measuring a different type and
yes we compared it against like I don't
know several dozen existing cohesion
measures turns out that the textual
cohesion conceptual cohesion how we call
it measures different properties of the
code so what can you do with it because
measuring everybody can invent a new
metric well as it turns out it turned
out to be a better defect predictor than
other cohesion metrics but better yet
that when we combine several cohesion
metrics obtained using structural
measures textual measures and dynamic
where there was a case the the
prediction power was significantly
better right and later on actually some
collaborators in um uh Italy um they
spun off and did an entire uh uh
desertation and future work on using
these measures because we also defined
coupling measures to guide refactoring
automated
refactoring okay
so these are the two
examples now there are people worked on
Cross cutting issues so as I said uh
everything I just described in these two
slides people have done it over and over
in at least 30 instances 30 different
problems what's the problem how do I
index it and so on and so forth now a
lot of researchers have done research on
that crosscuts the various applications
right so what are the issues Corpus
building identifier splitting was uh a
big research Don is here in the room
probably the expert in the field uh
synonym analysis to enhance the Corpus
and the queries for that matter
abbreviation ex expansion again I'm
pointing to done uh people use engram
analysis to enhance the Corpus and term
boosting you know if a term is a class
name it's more important than if it's a
random uh word in some comment on method
15 right
so um lot of research went on that I
don't know does anybody here in the room
did turn boosting I know Nick craft and
so on but okay um I told you that
selecting the right Tex retrieval model
uh model is still an open issue so
people looked at that two two two ways
uh people addressed this one by just
comparing them like really run it on the
same data which one is better second by
actually phrasing the selection as a
configuration problem and Dennis and his
students have done that in Sonia uh also
worked on that um and as far as I know
oh oh and Jane as well right with
genetic algorithms and so on right so
yeah um TI worked uh about 10 years ago
maybe on incremental indexing right
nobody SS um uh but people looked at
this right because as you have
I I'm sorry you see
okay yeah there there are a few papers
right it's it's it's it's a hard problem
so uh U software changes when do you
reindex and how how often and so on um
hard problem I'm not sure it differs
from the the problem in for the web of
updating web pages and that sort of
thing so I guess I don't know that that
problem in particular is different in
software engineering well I I think the
questions is probably different when
what are the triggers for indexing right
in software might be different than in
web I don't know this is a riches
question that even T at the time you
didn't address this issue you addressed
it how to do it rather than when right
yeah just how to do it exactly so so so
um if I recall correctly right um and
and people looked a little bit at
vocabulary right this was even before
the naturalness came about because
especially in in um um
all of these text retrieval approaches
there's this underlying assumption that
the things I'm trying to retrieve will
share vocabulary with the
queries right so at some point we
actually looked at uh quite a bit of
data to confirm that hypothesis and at
least in terms of uh in in one instance
uh like uh buggy code uh there is
statistical evidence that they share
more words with the bug description than
the non- bugy code h H reason you can
use something like this all right um
other cross cutting research problems
query
formulation um not that many people
worked on this as far as Sonia and a few
other people like what information you
put into the query right um
reformulation even fewer people work but
the two approaches are based on that are
common now on relevance feedback and on
query properties using machine
learning um result presentation I
mentioned it's spof summarization out of
it and of course information integration
there was research on adding structural
Dynamic and process information but one
thing we have not uh successfully
addressed now we know that it's good to
add dependencies it's we know it's good
to add stack traces or execution traces
and past changes and so on and so forth
what we don't know is is when and in
which order and we people tried it in a
variety of ways but there's no consensus
yes that how to do it properly right um
so that's a still big uh challenge
finally my last slide uh these are all
existing challenges and let me explain
one it's combination with natural
language processing IR those of you in
the field know it's just bag of words so
it only takes you that far
right it cannot distinguish between
actual meaning of opposite meanings
let's say of of phrases so um there's an
assumption that if you combine it with
more NLP it takes you one step further
how
open-ended
um matching the right tool and technique
to the task um we don't have the answer
I don't know whether LDA is a better
choice there than Lucine for concept
location the amount of data we have well
of course you're a fantic of LDA you
will say it's LDA and he's right we
don't have the answer really I don't as
far as I can tell there's not sufficient
evidence to support
either um better evaluation mechanism I
told you that there's not consensus you
pick random three papers they will have
different measure and metrics on the
same problem data availability um is
very little right the Denny some data
out there we have some data out there
half of it is not curated um uh we tend
to replicate whatever the last paper did
but we never really assessed the quality
of the data I think it's a major
fallacy um when I re if you if you get a
review of telling you this it's you know
it's from me um uh some researcher a few
years ago Don is we we did discuss
having a session at track on software
engine corpora which my uh spear had
collecting data nothing happened that
was well I I did check into it they
might be interested but we would need to
do a lot of upfront work exactly so so
we need some sort of community effort of
some sort um it's a challenge period
right um tool integration so as I said
we typically solve one part of the
problem right uh uh in concept location
if I want to address change completely I
need to tie this in with an impact
analysis
tool very few of us if any is even doing
that so so this is a little bit of
showstopper of going into industry an
adoption showstopper optimization um
most of the field correct me if I'm
wrong we cared about proof of concept as
I said what problems can be solved many
of our Solutions are not
exactly
optimal um well user studies I brought
that up uh
before very little research on the human
aspects here as in um as in uh how much
do we learn while we navigate right
switching from I'm searching for text
now versus I'm navigating dependencies
we don't know very little about those
clues in the code there are some uh
people working on right this um um
information foraging theories and and
and mapping them to softw engine
activities definitely fits
but we we're missing those what are the
scents and what are the clues that
allows you to switch between strategies
until we figure this out any any hope of
doing user studies uh as form of
evaluation it's anywh dwindled right so
what is the bottleneck um couple of
people Chris bar and Alex Soro had a
paper at e earlier this year and they
showed that
um it doesn't really matter whether I
rank the the buggy class uh one or 15
the bottleneck is once you find the
class is finding where it's the error is
still and text retrieval doesn't help
you with that so there are issues like
that
um
education um this is a problem um
probably everybody in soft raging faced
this uh we have to our our grad students
are sort sort of self-educating in NLP
and text tral and so on and I see
Crossing on the other say around
Jennifer now you're educating yourself
on software engineering right so there
is not uh um not a lot there and of
course
infrastructure
um most the research groups here we end
up implementing or rather reimplementing
all of our tools from scratch does
anybody here uses anybody else's tools
for anything from Corpus creation to
indexing not very little I think I mean
I'm just going to say something here
sure with trace this is my last slide so
that was the last word yes Trace laab is
is the step in the right direction I
mean for example we ran um our exceed
paper that we submitted this year one of
them I was able to reuse lots of
components that Dennis had produced and
some other people and I think that's
exactly so I think that's it's not quite
as negative as your kind no no no I'm
saying it's still a challenge right so
so you have one success in 15 years of
research that in my book that qualifies
still as a challenge right uh and and
that's the way to go yes you are I think
going in the right direction and we have
to move that forward I no offense I
don't think that problem has been solved
now just because you managed to do it
for your ex submission no I mean I was
just giving one dat of course of course
so regarding the consensus on measures
and suffering you're right I think
there's a lot of debate um I you know
for example I don't like precis recall I
don't even like a all that much um oh I
forgot to mention that one people use it
too yeah so so so so the the thing is
that um I'm wondering why it is
different in traditional information
material is it because programmers who
are the primary targets of these tools
are different sorts of animals from
ordinary humans who are using IR methods
or what's the deal so so there IR people
in the room so we should ask them but
here's my theory about it uh unproven
that is uh as I said we are solving a
very small problem by as as formulating
is as retrieval right and and and then
the success of your biggest problem this
is a small so uh whereas I don't know
maybe in some other fields the the
retrieval itself you're kind of done
when you found what you're looking for
with just tax retrieval that's rarely
happens in our
case why do you call it retrieval in
information processing it's called more
like inform extraction and for
information extraction they use uh more
uh much more um you know precise
instruments they just don't work they're
patterns they're they just write regular
Expressions to Define things so maybe
you could just not see it as a retriev
but as information extraction and
integration there are two reasons I call
it like that one because I'm poorly
educated in the
field like many of us I dare say um
again we're we're missing this cross F
theorization we are this is a great
place to start for sure I second um it
took us for example a long time in some
papers discussed this what's the
difference in in the sof engine context
between search and
retrieval search and and and the
consensus that came out it was the
search is when you know what you're
looking for like I'm looking for this
particular class so I can use regular
expression search to look for its name
and there it is retrieval is when I
don't know what I'm looking at and I
don't know how to describe it either
properly and developers do that every
day so uh it's one of those things they
recognize it when they see it but they
don't know how to describe it right
you're working on summarization we also
did some user studies Sonia did out
having people describe code it's a
disaster they can't they don't we we
don't it's a skill are not even teaching
them and often times they don't have and
they cannot describe it when they wrote
it they cannot describe it where they're
looking for it either well I'm
exaggerating of course but you you
understand what I'm highlighting I think
it's even debatable whether people
recognize it when they see it especially
in the concept location the first time
that you actually see the buggy location
no you're not going to find it yes you
don't understand that that is the
location of the that's what Alex told me
Alex s it was really Friday we we both
gave keyot at a workshop in Europe and
we we discussed an hour about this and
that's exactly what he said what they
found in user studies is what uh they
put the the the class that contained the
bug as first on the rank list developers
looked at it and just moved on because
they did not realize the bug is there
they eventually got back to it but it
took some steps so um I don't know if if
this type of uh retrieval or information
extraction or search is different
developers than the population at large
in other fields I'm suspecting it is but
so you know one thing I'm still not
clear about is that you know given like
Alex oro's user studies and all this um
should be formulate the problem this way
or should we formulate it differently in
other words the the problem of helping
developers locate where the bugs are
what is the right formulation do we have
the right formulation different
formulation yes problem is information
feel the right problem do we need we
need something else do we need like you
know some some other formal methods or
something that'll tell us okay here's
the bug and here's why so I'm not you
know that's something I'm actually going
need that's what I'm saying so we need
to once we Define a small slice of it
and and I I we agree that I can I can
phrase this as a retrieval problem or
information integration or search then
you need to define the other slices and
put them together and we as a field I I
I guess traceability is probably the one
that managed
to
close the
loop more than others to some degree but
yes in many of these tasks no we did
not so can can we use this discussion to
dig deeper into some problems like like
back to slide four or five where T it
said requirements and Bug locality and a
bunch of things like
that um so kind of it's It's also partly
and follow up to what Prem said about so
you've got this problem and you call it
bug locality that's a fairly well
defined software engineering problem
because you're trying to you know I mean
you could plant a bug and then you could
see if your Technique can find the bug
and how closely you can get to it and
then you could say well how so so my my
question is specifically how does the
text retrieval help you with the problem
and then the follow-up question would be
um what if I had some statistical
analysis techniques how does that help
me and then a follow-up question would
be suppose I add machine learning and I
have a corpus and then how does that
improve and then I don't know if I had
deep learning and all the other things
then do I even get more Improvement so
I'm thinking for every one of these
problems suppose I'm not a software
engineering researcher maybe I'm an NL
researcher or something and I'm trying
to understand how can I contribute to
one of these like requirements inl is
what is the oh it's very generic term
obviously but yeah like like not what's
the fragment that your text retrieval
the fragment of requirements analysis
problems that you address with text
retrieval but what is the requirements
analysis problem right and then how can
all of these techniques right be brought
to bear so I guess I want to encourage a
um we should pick I didn't want to go
Define all 30 of them for the
non-software engineers because it would
have taken me three days exactly but if
we had a couple of concrete examples
that are really high leverage areas
where we think we can make progress
anybody who wants to okay requirements
entry Jane maybe can talk more about it
but one of the problems your students
did that was clustering requirements
right so I mean in the area of
requirement analysis um this is not an
area that I've worked in specifically
but one of the big open areas is um
looking for nocuous ambiguities looking
for what nocuous ambiguities so in other
words in the requirements um there's
sometimes conflicting requirements and
um they they go unnoticed and the search
for nocuous ambiguities is finding
ambiguities that um if you
don't too so too soft yep um nocuous
it's not on anyway nocuous ambiguities
are um looking for um using natural
language processing techniques um some
people like
Bashan and um ven Vincenzo um jaesi have
worked in this area so they've been
using natural language processing
methods to identify um ambiguities that
are going to impact the correctness of
the system if you don't figure them out
in advance um that's one of the big
areas of application of NLP actually in
requirements analysis and um I know my
um industry collaborators have
previously um told me one problem that
they have is um when they enter a new
field um for example in positive train
control um they get all of these domain
documents and they want to try and make
sense of all of this mass of data so
that they can extract requirements from
that um not necessarily written
perfectly but to extract knowledge that
would lead to requirements um that they
could specify so I think these are two
of the big open areas that um could
absolutely benefit from natural language
analysis so are there some specific
objectives that you know like how well
am I doing extracting the requirements
so that I could tell if I you know use
some higher powered techniques I I would
know that I'm doing
better um I would say um I don't know
enough about the nocus ambiguity area
obviously they've got their metrics and
I I just am not completely up to date
with that um in the other area of um
kind of domain analysis and extracting
requirements um it's just a it's an
really open area area um I think I don't
think there's that much work that's
being done in it in terms of um defining
it as clearly as some of these other
tasks that we know what we want to
measure let me let me give another uh
example um in sub at Pennsylvania worked
with uh Aran Joi for a while on like an
FDA document that states all the rues
regulations for Infusion pumps right and
so their goal is to extract policies
from the documents and what I don't
understand is um how do they know if
they've extracted you know half of them
or all of them how do they know if they
um if the specification that results
that's more formal is uh accurate um how
do they know if two of them contradict
each other and anyway so if you define
all the problems associated with this
natural language analysis task where
you're trying to get specs from which
you can produce software um then
then can we look at our Arsenal I mean
how do we approach the research in these
areas to see how well we can do yeah I
also wanted to ask you I mean the
requirements as opposed to code is still
uh declarative correct so in that sense
it's more um should be more um uh
similar to to to test I mean to to to
which is not requirement so to to me the
requirements and code are so such two
different classes of text because the
code describes a moving system it's like
a describing a um you know it's an it's
it's um system that act acts and has
consequences and results which are used
so so it's a completely different type
of um uh text than requirements so
methods which could be um uh appropriate
for the requirements analysis might not
at all and not even be bad to use on on
on code because code is such a specific
totally unique type of test that's
correct absolute correct statement yes
for a mismatch problem it's a very
well-known problem that's exactly what
and also uh look uh the approach is even
that Bashar did there was just just
straight use of an NLP technique that
happen and and this this text happened
to be requirements documents right but
yes the challenges come when we have to
put up with audities of the code and
extracting that additional information
and see how it matches the TX but even
with requirements maybe we should just
separate like what could be what are the
particular task which need to be done in
requirements and then figure out what
the NLP field could really bring the the
best uh to to Bear whereas code is first
of all you need to
describe what kind of text it is there
just there's lots of declar of code
though there's code that actually
declares what it's going to do right but
she meant it differently right so no but
if you go look at deop stuff right now
they have things where you say I have
the following tasks and they have to do
the following things yeah that's all I
have to say but let me add something
which is have to do the following things
requirements do not tell you what to do
the following things requirements is
understand says um it's basically
functionality this is this is what it uh
takes as an input and that's what we
should be to see as a result depend well
depending yeah depending what how you
define requirements to yeah let me add
something hold on because maybe this is
not obvious for the non-software
engineers these tasks we can easily
cluster them in four or five very
distinct subsets of software engineering
that have their own publication venues
their own conferences their own
everything and and uh very few of us can
comfortably move between all
four this is not just one field
here um yeah sorry uh so I just wanted
to comment about this question about uh
what are some specific tasks that NLP
might be able to help us with today or
tomorrow um so I I do want to miror what
Jane said on the requirements analysis
one question we've been looking at has
been ambiguity in the requirements
documents so um and I talked to this
with David as well I'm not sure how
statistical NLP I'm not saying it can't
this thing I don't know how it would be
able to tell
us um when that something in a document
say a requirements document is not uh
well it's grammatically correct it's
statistically there but it doesn't um
it's uh not um doesn't mean what you
might think that it means so you so just
for an example if somebody in a
requirements document put something
that's not really shouldn't quite put in
there something like uh the system
should respond as fast as
possible or um the system something it
should be about 6 feet long or should
take about 6 seconds what does about
mean what is uh as close as possible
these kind of what do you mean unication
it's vague yeah so it's it's like a vag
it's not
ambiguity yes you should what's that you
should so I don't have to do
it exactly terms like this so uh so this
vus question yeah that's absolutely
right I got my terms mixed up yes so
this vas question I don't know I know
that it would be it is an area that
industry is interested in some
collaborators of mine have looked at it
have been very curious about this
question uh but uh so far we haven't
discovered an offthe shelf natural
language technique which
we Colin I'm told that's actually on but
that you have to hold it much closer I
have to hold it like that that's perfect
okay anyway I'm just throwing that on
the table as a problem that is out there
today that no industry is interested in
could somebody use us a an example of
ambiguity it's sometimes stronger than
ambiguity you can have conflicting
requirements essentially asking you
fundamentally to do opposite things
sometimes not ambig I think the issue
about ambiguity and I can't think of an
example right now but the issue is that
every every English sentence could be
interpreted in an ambiguous way it has
multiple meanings and the thing about
the nocuous ambiguity is the meanings
that actually impact the way people will
interpret the requirement and therefore
possibly build different systems as a
result I have several examples on it's
probably ambiguity when you have like
should something should behave like this
I mean it could be like the system is
you know meant I mean designed to be
like that or the inputs it's more like a
precondition where you better pass me
things that make my system clear that
way
I imagine quantifiers would be as well
like all
request so when when I said ambiguity
really
didn't ambiguity is when a term could
refer to more than one thing and you
don't know which thing yes the use of a
pronoun that you don't know what it's
referring to could create ambiguity
pronoun the terminers are often causing
ambiguity when you say the class the
object should do that Which object
you're talking about exactly this is
probably very
and I think the issue of should and
could and stuff is just bad requirements
writing as opposed to really sorry but
we should have TR papers as well we
should so I I have this question like
this seems like an interesting problem I
wonder um about nocuous requirements in
particular um has there been an attempt
to formalize the requirements to the
point that some like theorem prover
could identify that these things are
innocuous like I feel like most are
probably written in um unqualified or
unrestricted natural language text right
yes and but have there at least been
small Corporal where people have tried
to write down a formal representation of
what those requirements are to the point
that that a theorem prover or a Z3 or
something like that could operate over
it well now I wish I'd read those papers
more
carefully this is what happened with
compiler specifications they used to be
done in natural language and then alol
came which was the first program
language to have
let's try to if you raise your hand I'll
try to come to you I was saying that
this problem has been solved with
compiler specification in the past
alcohol was the first language to have
its syntax formally specified before
that it was done in natural language so
what Chris was saying the it's like
doing the same thing now if possible
it's more difficult with requirement
specification hey J is close sorry just
cuz I'm next to um so I think there's
been a lot of people that have advocated
writing requirements in semi semi
structured formats or in formal ways but
the reality is that just doesn't happen
and um industry doesn't want for the
most part industry doesn't want to do
that they want to write requirements in
natural language text and therefore that
is you know so you can you can tackle
the problems in two ways one remove
ambiguity by insisting on formal
requirements or facing reality and
accepting that people don't write them
that way and dealing with what we have
which is natural
language yeah so Jane's absolutely right
there's a cultural context if you look
at modern software development
especially Agile development they
prioritize talking to the customer over
documentation that's in their Manifesto
it's basically this little Marxist
Manifesto of how we want to do software
and most people have bought an in to
this now well not most but a lot have
bten into it so you're not going to get
any kind of formalized requirements
anymore regulated markets you do
but communication but there still
usually natural language and not using a
formal structure so I do know one
project at SRI where they used a
semantic parser to try to map a natural
language specification into a formal
specification I don't know if other
people know other other projects but I
do know one on that just because it
happens to be done one of the persons
was the wife of one of my former PhD
students but I forget the name of the
system but they had data for this or it
was like I think they use some training
data they don't have a lot not
surprisingly but I think that is an
interesting area like right
now we're discussing this no notion of
what I'll call a supervision signal as a
either an all or nonone case like so for
many of these requirements we we
certainly won't have a formal
specification I totally believe that
um but there may be ways that we can try
to exploit the specifications that are
available in certain projects to
leverage um uh for those those projects
for which we don't have formal
specifications or we we might have a
looser supervision signal like say
somebody was willing to identify that
these two requirements were innocuous I
never heard that word that's like
innocuous but without the is okay okay
um so yeah but so so getting some
visible traces of what the system should
be able to learn may may give it a at
least an approximate supervision signal
but I mean I think there's a lot of
research going on right now in the NLP
front in how we should do meaning
representation um and there are some
attempts to do generalized meaning
representation like abstract meaning
representation banks are being built up
now funded by the linguistic data
Corporation um and they try to be
application independent um there's a lot
of compromises made there I think a lot
of the people in the next session will
be talking about uh domain specific
semantics and how we can have some tasks
that address those but um yeah but I
mean I don't know if you could find even
the small corpora for which there are
both natural language and formalized uh
requirements that that might be a very
useful resource just for research well
what we have it's natural language
requirements and
code that's
way but that's what we have right that's
in the medical infusion pump they have
um kind of the the written
specifications and formal models right
we do have have that in one domain Rel
Le so I think uh one thing we should be
aware of with all of this stuff or at
least the vast majority of it is it uses
what audris mcus calls operational data
this is data that's left behind that was
never intended for most of these tasks
this is basically mining the artifacts
and results of software development and
most of it was not intentional to do any
of this whatsoever so I think that's why
we're stuck in the text retrieval domain
because we're dealing with scraps bits
and pieces that are left behind hints of
the past that maybe are helpful but it's
not data that was meant for that this is
just stuff that people put into
repositories whether accidentally
automatically because their boss told
them to or because it helped communicate
it's not necessarily for any of these
tasks so uh so as I was digging here I
uh hope I didn't rip too far away from
the conversation but there was a
question about the uh some specific
cases where this might be useful and I
do apologize if the ambiguity or
vagueness of if I don't quite know the
exact term but the problem is like this
and this is an actual problem that
occurred at my industrial collaborator
just one example uh the software should
have uh or the software it's a saying
what the requirement should be in the
future um so the software in the future
should have reduced memory usage
compared to their competitor their
unnamed competitor
well this actually led to a question of
whether they meant reduced maximum
allocation space or reduced accesses to
memory so that's just an example that
maybe there's a technique out there
another example from related literature
is if a bank customer contain uh
maintains a minimum balance in his
account there is no monthly service
charge so that actually raises the
question do you mean to calculate it
based on and and the the regulations are
not clear do you mean to calculate it
based on a per day basis or is it an
average over the month so these kind of
questions come up in requirements a lot
and
uh you know what we need we need a
dialogue we need a dialogue system a
clarifier saying what do you mean by
should here you know it's ridiculous to
to to have shoulds in the requirements
because they're by minimum balance yeah
so so should should problem um but also
the question of memory usage yeah can we
say that memory usage we must not
actually we shouldn't have it is
actually and um so the tool that the
that the industrial collaborator using
at at at the time when I walked in there
actually did what you were saying and
words like should might yeah it's like a
checker it's a checker but that's that's
a separate issue than right uh you know
there were attempts to have what they
call controlled language in certain
companies they were grammars how you
write your like uh aircraft especially
because or or some kind of um um
procedures when for instance you you
never uh put the if behind the verb
because they push the button and then
they see the if right so um so so that
is a controlled language but it was not
uh certain industries were like aircraft
maintenance really adopted that and
pretty much still use it now but you
cannot have it for all software because
it's unrealistic so but the question is
but still some of the checkers which
could check for certain cases obvious
cases of vagueness or under
specification or whatever you call it um
uh nocu uh um ambiguity I also never
heard the word nocus it's actually
interesting um so maybe maybe that could
be could be um well uh used in the by
the
industry I'm actually so this is a
question for the software engineering
people so um how many of these nocuous
cases are ambiguous but if you have kind
of the domain knowledge about what's
going on then you can kind of uh look at
the pragmatics it's actually not
ambiguous
um so yeah I think there's some
ambiguity about the meaning of the word
ambiguous so you know I I think it
relates to the fact that you know
software engineering has you know spes
many different domains it goes you know
from medicine to all this stuff and
every domain has their own sorts of
problems I guess one question I have is
if if one have to have access to a
sufficient number of documents in a
field is it possible to identify terms
that are important but an ambiguous so
so other words just statistically can
you run over a large cice and say these
terms areally used but they're used
different
ways and so then that gives us
motivation to actually go off and create
an anology you know Define terms
precisely and create an antology for
that so yeah there is work on a problem
called sense induction in in lexical
semantics where you cluster the context
in which a word appears and you can
determine how you know if it is
ambiguous and how many senses it might
have I mean the statistical thing
technique but there are methods for
doing that's usually g under the title
sense induction how much data do you
need answer more the more the better but
no but you we
don't give you have to try it and see
but they're pretty standard technique so
supposing Sal could find a collection of
all the FAA documents right ever written
could you go through these documents say
these terms in the anautics domain are
ambiguous to some extent I think it
might the current technology might be
able to do a somewhat decent job on
that
can you take just 30 seconds and
introduce yourself okay hi I'm Percy
leang um I'm from Stanford and I work on
natural language processing and machine
learning um since I guess uh maybe just
to follow up on my comment I guess one
thing that I think could be relevant is
that I mean since we're talking about
natural language in the context of code
right I think it's useful to think about
kind of this notion of grounded language
where um it's not just kind of a
language and text understanding problem
that we've been probably kind of if you
say okay let's use NLP techniques
probably the most NLP techniques will be
trying to focus on understanding this
kind of the sentence in isolation which
um inevitably there's always kind of
ambiguity but perhaps by looking at what
kind of actually makes sense in a given
context so for example if you have
something like I don't know uh put a
initialize every element of this Vector
with a list or something um it's
probably a maybe a different list uh
because that's the only thing that makes
sense in the given code context so
there's actually kind of a lot of
opportunities for a richer connection
between the um natural language
understanding and actually the structure
that code gives
you so next to get off the topic too
much but I just wanted to mention uh you
know so defect prediction for example is
one of those domains where there's
actually a lot of maturity in the data
sets if you're looking for data sets and
you want to play with them defect
prediction there a lot of data there's
you just go to open science. us/ REO
this is Tim men's baby and you know it's
a lot of data in there from you know
various people have generated over the
years and most of it is fairly
reasonably curated um you know so open
science. us/ repost there L there
but um not a lot of textual data there
there is
some it's growing it's growing pred
there because defect detection is more
about kind of structural things not
always uhuh no no no but but I guess the
question was really how do we leverage
structure in the code to actually um
understand better uh right comments and
and code in vice versa that that's
really the point how do we merge
semantics in the identifiers and how do
we actually also utilize structural
information on code for understanding
code in comments that that's really I
guess a really interesting question
because it can be tackled with
statistical NLP
methods um so I just have a question I
guess for the software engineering
people that I'm trying to kind of get my
head around like what the current
techniques do and what they maybe don't
do that they could do um so is all of
this based on just like matching of
words or is there a lot of like pattern
matching as well like saying this set of
words matches to this pattern of code
even though there's like no word overlap
between it um or is it all just word
overlap that's I couldn't quite get that
the talk the short answer is if you
utilize techniques for example like
latent semantic indexing which rely on
dimensional a reduction in that case you
can pick up similar things which don't
have exact words in the query it's going
to be based on Curren Rel cooccurrences
so depending which underlying technique
you use if it's Vector space these are
exact matches if it's lat semantic
indexing or some other technique which
does Dimension reduction but you can
pick up these there phrase level
matching I think T could talk about that
and and and as it goes to TI I want to
add that
typic typically the various sources of
information are combined right so the
words are there but then you look where
exactly and how to let's say uh two
methods or two classes that have shared
words also relate by control or data
flow if they do it means something if
they don't it means something else
although they share the same number of
words okay okay right depends on your
task
okay and sometime in some application
for example you uh you have the API in
one language you have the other API in
different language they use different
terminology sometime you cannot look in
the similar text to matches uh so in
this case the mapping solution
statistically is really helpful uh you
know simple mapping IBM model good work
uh but the more sophisticated I think
we'll get better
results I guess this is a question about
how kind of the kind of the academic
work on this kind of relates to what's
actually uh done in industry is it's
kind of many of these things are part of
the um standard development cycle of I
mean there's a lot of software being
written so I guess what do they do and
what is which of these areas I guess are
kind of most
uh so I question I guess you want us to
rank this by by Industrial someh well
you
can to that well I I'll start any uh
there's a bunch of them that have to do
with software change that's what
developers do for a living every day
right more the question was what do they
do um in industry is it similar to
what's in the papers or is it completely
different no it's it's in in most cases
similar these are not made up problems
but
in terms of maturity right A lot of
these would be great if you could solve
them but we might not be there yet so in
terms of what's had it what's kind of
come far enough that it's had an impact
into industrial practice how oh yeah so
so U you you know somebody mentioned I
don't remember might have been in to's
talk uh talked about Olo Google code and
so on so a lot of code search engines
and repositories when we started working
that this 10 years 15 years ago they
didn't exist now they're out there so
that
I know for a fact of many comp Microsoft
research Gina venolia work right she she
she built this sort of ir engines to
query across uh all of their artifacts
inside Microsoft um I know of a lot of
companies who built their own internal
search engines right so so a lot of this
uh did go through yeah right so so those
would be cases where the information
need is code I'm looking for code that
uses that keyword and that's mature but
maybe applying it to some of some of
these other problems is that still more
of an open challenge or a lot of almost
everything here it's code except maybe
some of the requirements analysis uh let
me think what else
but anything on bug reports kind of
weird cons yeah right but eventually
gets to code right so you're looking at
bug reports with a purpose to change to
fix it but I mean I guess just to give
an example that I don't what you meant
exactly well if you look at bugy
duplication if you look at bugy
duplication trying to find similar
documents
it's of okay if it's in bug
triage yeah and I'm going back to what
what Abram said before I I loved it and
I cannot emphasize it enough we're using
these techniques because the information
we're trying to put together was not
really meant for that it's it's
accidental there but speaking of what uh
propagates to Industry like sold just
send me uh a link to the paper which is
called extending nocus ambiguity
analysis for anaer in natural language
requirements
2010 it's uh it's from UK and Ireland
and it's even extending analysis so it
it apparently there was already someone
else which they are extending for an eff
so I wonder whether this we talk about
uity like how the state of the art is on
that now if their papers like that in
Jame so I think one of the challenges um
we have in software engineering is
understanding how we take these
Solutions the the very last Mile and I
don't know for those of you who were um
at FSC in Hong Kong last year um John
Panic gave a really good talk and one of
the things he was talking about um was
how they'd actually try to take the um
fault prediction code and just feed it
to the programmers to the developers and
one of the things he said the problems
that they have is even if you feed it
really quickly um and it comes to the
developers like a couple of hours you
know after a couple of hours or
something like that they've already
fixed that problem so you're already
running running the code on kind of a
changing Target and so the developers
were um frustrated about that I don't
were you at that talk by John penck Prem
in FC in Hong Kong yeah yeah do you
remember his comment okay W pay
attention but anyway I think that I
think it kind of characterizes the
challenges we have in software
engineering it's not enough to just kind
of deliver something that's you know 90%
correct this amount of imprecision and
the challenges of actually putting it
into the um workplace make it really
difficult so I think this is an open
issue for
us but I guess uh you answer from
another question what what are the
remaining problems that can be
successfully tackled with a statistical
NLP and other NLP techniques which are
we still have five minutes to discuss
that so so one thing I was just brought
up U by Microsoft colleague here is is
um you know statistical methods right in
general um I guess this is not meant as
a criticism but in some settings they're
great because they just tell me what to
do and it's fine but in some other
settings they give me some stuff and
it's very hard to explain why they gave
me that thing you know so and you know I
think it's a good point that my
colleague was making here is that like
you know if you can't explain to a
programmer why you came up with with
that thing you know what are they going
to do with
this well so because I kind of sit
between research and practice one of my
mandates is to take research and
actually put it into practice and that
has proven like much more difficult than
I thought it would be the big well one
of the big challenges is putting
something into practice and then
developers just don't trust it and there
have been times where we have taken some
like say bug prediction model that's
super super accurate and put in front of
developers and they don't use it and
we've actually resorted to using a much
simpler model that has worse performance
but that I can explain to a developer
and then it has adoption so it's like we
we think that performance is key right
that that's the ultimate but in fact
understandability and explainability um
is just as important if not more
so so back in the 8S I'm one of the few
people here that remember AI in the 80s
there's a whole bunch of work on
explainable Expert systems there's a lot
of work historically on it and and
certainly more rule-based techniques are
a little easier to do that but it's not
at all impossible for a statistical
model to give you the most important
factors that influenced its decision
right I mean so it's not like a
statistical model can't explain itself
it certainly can't to some extent it's
not going to give you every Factor
because there's a lot of little pieces
that may be added up but it can give you
the highest impact features that caused
it to make some decision that's
relatively easy maybe a lot of the tools
don't easily provide facilities for
doing that but in principle it's pretty
straightforward so Pandora tells you why
you're listening to what you're
listening to I mean you can I did work
on explaining recommenders that's an
interesting subtask
yeah like um one um one trick from the '
80s that I don't remember myself but I
did read
about is um you know you could just
train some kind of rule based system on
the output of the high performing
classifier and say you just pretend to
programmers when they Kevin did some of
this Stu did he really yeah oh okay when
was this do you remember the
8S well sometimes it's more so look if
you want to successfully use a defect
predictor it's not enough to tell you
why the tool tells you this class has a
high defect potential it should also
tells you what you should change and
preferably how this is a tool chain
right so and you you're you're still
there the developer to make decisions
along the way so uh typically that's the
other problem I kept emphasizing we're
solving just a subset of a bigger
problem you know sometimes you know for
a programmer you know it may not be
necessary to you know supposing the
programmer isues a query as in this Bing
code search thing you know you show a
query and the and the thing retrieves
some code um you know it may be
difficult in that particular stud to
provide an explanation for why that code
is reved but it may be enough to provide
some analoges or something you know
uh the analogs maybe kind of enough for
the programmer to understand you know
why this thing is being retrieved so in
addition to retrieving the specific
answer maybe sort of retrieving some
high very something like a support VOR
something very close to that you know
some sort of like kernel type thing some
something very close which is similar to
the answer you know probabilistically
similar to the answer that we retrieved
might be helpful for the program even
though full logical explanation is not
forthcoming my my metaphor was always a
text retrieval in software especially
when you're retrieving code will get you
in the zip code and then you need static
analysis or something else to find your
way inside that neighborhood so it's
it's the way it
works any other comments questions I
think we are out of time
unfortunately uh but we have very
productive discussion which is going to
be summarized so everybody will see the
summary of it in the end and um should
we just call a break yeah let's call a
break and pick up again at 10:45 so uh
let me introduce our next session on
natural language programming and
semantic parsing um and I'll welcome to
the stage Ray Mooney who will be giving
the first talk in this session okay so I
I built this to sort of introduce
semantic parsing to our software
engineering folks but maybe it's a
little redundant at this time but maybe
there'll be at least a little more
insight here so like I said this is a
area I've worked on for a long time and
I've tended to Define it this way
mapping a natural language sentence to a
detailed repres presentation of its
complete meaning in a fully formal
language and what became a little bit of
a a famous little Benchmark problem uh I
worked with a student of John zeli back
in the mid90s we put this together and
it's a pretty toy problem at at this
point but it illustrates the point and
the biggest application of this stuff is
database query stuff so I ask a question
in English like what is the smallest
state by area I get some logical form
out that's actually executable we
originally did this in prologue but you
could do it in any sort of formal query
language and then that goes goes to a
database and you get an answer out so
this work started actually as as Charles
alluded to actually a long time ago in
the late 60s and early 70 people tried
to handb build these systems uh and that
went on for a long time and and I've
always tried to view semantic parsing as
sort of a translation between natural
and formal languages so this is a
picture I made for one of our systems we
developed called was where machine
translation looks at translating from
one natural language to another semantic
Paran of VI is looks at translating from
a natural language to a formal computer
language compiling translates one formal
language into another and then tactical
generation it's probably more now known
as surface generation within the NL
generation Community Maps a formal
language back to a to a natural language
and I made this slide originally to
motivate the use of of a technique that
we developed using synchronous grammars
I don't know how many of you know about
that because it was originally developed
for compilers right then it was adapted
to do machine translation and then we
adapted it to do semantic parsing and I
really do view this as as sort of the
nice big picture of looking at at all
these different sorts of tasks but like
I said people tried to can build these
mapping from natural to farmal languages
starting like like Bill Woods in the in
the in the late ' 60s and early' 70s but
it was always difficult it was tried to
be commercialized at the time I I always
like to tell people this story real
quick that sem Manch people know what
they originally did they didn't do virus
and Mal code detection they did semantic
baring that was their but they didn't
make a go of it which is why they
switched their their their their their
business model so I said the way to do
this is to learn so I was the first one
I think to really seriously look at how
do we learn these things where I just
give you pairs training pairs of natural
language and formal representations I
usually call those Mrs for just meaning
representation and then you have a
semantic pars of learning that then
learns a semantic part automatically can
map language to meaning so my real
contribution to this was starting in the
mid90s to really try to focus on how do
we learn these things and since then
that's turned in to a little bit of a
cottage industry and I was sort of
working in isolation for many years but
then thanks to to Luke zelm and Percy
Lang who were both happy to have here
and maybe some other folks it's become a
fairly uh widespread area now just a
little bit to about what's been focused
on lately one is reducing supervision so
I don't have to give it full sentences
and meanings I can just give it like
query answer pairs that's something that
Percy uh worked on amongst others and
other types of weak supervision or even
unsupervised semantic parsy a student
here at udab uh H funun who's in the NLP
group with Chris worked on unsupervised
semantic parsing another big topic
lately has been scaling this up from
these toy little databases to really
fairly large uh databases like Freebase
again people like Luke and and Percy
have done a lot of work uh on that
another thing that that's come up
already is this idea of grounded
learning we don't just we actually
connect language to perception and
action there's been a fair bit of
semantic parsing work on like commands
for robots so I've done a certain amount
of this and some other people either
simulated or real robots where you you
actually translate natural language into
a sequence of commands for a robot and
then the most recent thing that I've
gotten interested and makes connections
most to this field and why I'm here is
is okay well database query is a type of
of of program language that cerative
program language but it's very limited
and there hasn't been much work on
mapping natural language to other types
of programming languages other than
database query and so I was did a sub my
sabatical here last fall with Chris and
we started this nice project that he's
going to talk about next on actual
natural language programing for this
particular task of of if this then that
uh uh queries for those of you or
commands for those who are familiar with
that so okay so that's just my really
quick introduction to hopefully this
session that a lot of my good friends in
in this area will talk more about
details
thanks um okay so I I'll talk about this
particular application I'm I'm calling
this language to code and some people
might take exception to the code side of
it just because the code is really not
that complicated we're only looking at
simple if this if this then that style
recipes but um but I think there's a lot
of linguistic complexity here and
ambiguity resolution that needs to
happen so it's an interesting problem
from that domain um uh I'm so I'm I'm
thinking about like end user programming
in the context of um personal agents
more and more like I don't know if I'm
sure everybody in the room is familiar
with Siri um the co-founders of Siri
went on to form another startup called
Viv that was intended their goal is to
try to hand handle questions like this
right like on the way to my brother's
house I need to pick up some cheap wine
that goes well with lasagna and if you
think about this I could try to parse it
and analyze it and turn it into some
sort of complicated structure execution
graph that might be like a sequel
grammar or something under the hood but
it's a real like bit of code that we
should assemble based on that language
that's grounded in a number of real
world databases this is not my graph by
the way this is stolen directly from
their wired article I just think this is
nice motivation so um I like the area
that they're going into um but
unfortunately I think we need to
bootstrap our process somehow right like
we can't start from nothing uh we need
at least some sort of supervision signal
to learn from um on the other hand uh so
these those are sort of very complex
programs on the simple end of the
spectrum um there's a lot of effort
these days in startups like wit.ai that
got bought out by Facebook that's
focused on um what I think of as single
function execution right like if I have
a command like set the temperature to
70° in my bedroom I'd like to have that
execute by changing some settings on my
Nest right um and they don't do anything
more complicated than that which makes
it really easy for random developers to
take natural language statements and
turn them into Json basically so some
schematized representation that can then
be executed over but the focus is simply
on these single um statements so one of
the things that Ry and I started talking
about to try to get toward um natural
language programming is to try to find
some existing resources that would allow
us to train systems and one of the most
ripe resources out there was this if
this then that data site um so if you if
you go there you uh people can go and
author simple programs that um use a
number of channels uh they they can
watch Facebook and Trigger things to
happen with their internet of things or
so on um and then uh provide a natural
language description for what's
happening uh for each of those program
prams um and if you go and craw their
site you can find like hundreds of
thousands of these little programs it's
really kind of a fascinating data set
exactly for that reason um let me look
at some specific instances so people are
doing things like uh if there's a carbon
monoxide emergency then I can turn all
the lights in my house to Red like you
go to DEFCON 5 or something like that um
I could track the position changes in a
company so every time I see something
that happens on LinkedIn I could add a
line item to a Google Drive spreadsheet
um I could grab random Wikipedia
meetings um you could do all sorts of
stuff right and these are actual recipes
that I saw as well as the natural
language descriptions that were
associated with them right so you can
see this is like evidence of how messy
and noisy those natural language might
be and yet we should still be able to
interpret this stuff at least to some
degree right um so that's the task that
Rey and my colleague Michelle and I took
upon ourselves while Ry spent some time
here um uh as far as the website is
concerned you author your recipes using
a simp web goey we took it upon
ourselves to try to schematize it into a
programming language I kind of hate
calling it a programming language
because it has like one statement and a
limited list of actions and so on but it
seems like a nice starting point
nonetheless and our first attempt to to
address this problem was to look at it
like a machine translation problem
because I've been doing that for like 10
years now and the whole world to me
looks like a machine translation problem
um but uh then we found out that the the
association between the text and the
code was not all that strong and so we
started have having to reach more
towards uh program synthesis based
methods and we have a paper at ACL about
this um from earlier this year um oh boy
I'm running short on time um so the data
was very noisy one of the things we
wanted to be able to do is see whether
humans could agree on this task so we
also took a bunch of these uh if task
descriptions and gave them to Mechanical
turkers and asked the turkers to try to
reconstruct the program um and so it was
very interesting like we put this up on
M Turk and got some very immediate
responses so people are definitely
willing to do this kind of stuff in fact
bunch of people were excited about it
and said hey it looks like we're trying
to train a better personal agent how can
we help you
more um but uh let's see I the
accuracies are maybe if you look at the
initial accuracies then they're not all
that encouraging um but that's on all of
the recipes many of the recipe titles
are just terrible people will type ASDF
or something for the recipe title so one
of the things we did is tried to subset
those recipes into um those that are
written only in English um those that
are intelligible as far as the turkers
are concerned and those situations where
turkers agree and it seems like under
those conditions we can get um 60 70%
accuracy on this task which means we can
do some interpretation of these
moderately complex programs um so I
think there's a bunch of next steps here
we can look at like sort of refinement
dialogues that's one thing that I'm
working on we could try to extend the
language Beyond just if then um looking
at feedback loops is really fascinating
but um but I think using this found data
resource to help bootstrap natural
language understanding is is an
interesting Direction
oh
there okay uh hi I'm G Buel I'm a first
year PD student at University of
Washington I'm advised by Dan weld um uh
and I'm going to be talking about
synthesizing conditional programs from
national language it's sort of an
extension of the work uh the Chris and
Professor money have been working on um
it's an incredible disadvantage to
follow the experts but I'll try my best
to motivate uh uh the pro problem okay
so personal bus assistance are youday we
all have one in our pockets uh right now
um so I'll give you a real life example
that I tried so I went and asked Siri
and Google now uh is it going to rain
tomorrow and both of them actually give
pretty good responses gave out a table
of the WEA forecast of the entire week
but then I changed the query a little
bit and said uh notify me if it's going
to rain tomorrow and both of them gave
really wag responses uh Siri actually
thought I was asking it to set a
reminder with the title if it's going to
rain tomorrow and Google now just turned
to web search so clearly these
assistants today are not capable of
understanding these simple instructions
and and the motivation is that these
person this assistant you just don't
want to query them your question
answering with them you want to be able
to them to instruct them learn your
preferences and and do do do things on
your
behalf uh so again as Chris mentioned
this is really simple program you want
this assistant to simp uh understand at
this point which is if the booing Reign
is true then call this notify function
and they can't even do that right now uh
so we've been thinking about solving
this problem um uh using dialog systems
um uh and uh so there's a kind of a
parts clarify execution Loop here U
where the first step is given an enter
you try to par the input query and then
uh based upon uh whatever prediction it
makes a decision theoretic controller
tries to decide whether to ask for a
clarification from the human or whether
to execute it and this is based on a
utility model of the human and the
confidence it has on the output it could
clarify about the functions and the
arguments uh if it executes it can get
the feedback from the human um so I just
started at this point so as a warning I
would like to say that we don't have any
numb coog numbers to show you guys uh
but I would love to he back U hear
feedback on um the approach we're about
to
follow um so as Chris mentioned one of
the uh one of the ACL papers tried to do
this uh there are a lot of data which
try to map these sentences like archive
your Miss calls from Android to Google
drive to the appx sytax trees um and I
won't I won't explain the paper much but
basically uh one of the ways I like to
view it is that it was a subsect
selection problem in the formal language
grammar that you're trying to map to
um so I've been thinking about improving
their parer and one of the ways to
improve the parer is by relaxing the
independence assumptions so if you
attended Daniel Do's uh talk yesterday
he talked about you can think of parsing
as a as a sequence of steps you have to
make and you have to decide at each
point how much history to condition on
so I'm basically trying to uh use more
history to condition on so that's one of
the things a challenges sparsity in the
data um another way to improve parsing
that we've been thinking about is using
another source of alternate form of
supervision so we've been thinking of
using API documentation as a source of
we weak or uh distant supervision if you
want to use that term um so if you go to
if.com you can actually extract these
really nice descriptions for all these
functions so for
example uh for any Miss calls you can
get this really nice descriptions saying
this trigger fires every time you miss a
phone call on an Android device and I
think a lot of you can see the a lot of
trigger words that you can use to
accommodate these features in the
graphical model
U and the benefits of using this kind of
supervision are twofold you cannot just
improve the paring but you can
automatically try to extend to new
function as soon as the developer push
them to the
API okay so now I'll talk about
clarification so um learning from us
interaction is this fascinating idea
there was a paper by Eric horvitz called
principles of mixed initiative systems
uh which talks more more more about this
but here so for example example
clarification system could ask for uh
the same example notify me if it's going
to rain what do I how do I notify you do
you want me to get an send you an SMS or
an email notification so so in the cases
where the queries under
specified uh while we interested in
learning uh from user interactions uh in
the long term we initially been thinking
about using crowd sourcing uh for
bootstrapping the system um and in this
case it it can be actually hard to get
high quality uh dialog logs so we've
been thinking of using more complex
workflows like itative Improvement
workflow
where you basically ask a question from
the worker and then improve till you
have a reasonable description or the
labels you have and then you finally
vote on it and get high quality data and
another uh and you have a decision
theoretic controller again uh to get the
good workers to get label the data U the
benefits are gain to full you get high
higher quality data and you can also
learn the utility model about the users
um thank you that's
it
hi I'm yav I'm going to very briefly
talk about some of the work I've done
situated learning and understanding of
natural language so uh Ray would
introduced to us earlier this problem of
semantic parsing we want to take
sentences and M them to logical form
representation of the their meaning and
this gives us this very formal
representation that the system can
respond to and also very expressive
representation that can capture the
complexities of natural language So
within this problem H my work focused on
recovering the context dependent meaning
of language how we can use a various
learning signals that requires less
supervision and how we can do this All
In scale I'm not going to discuss the
scaling aspect H in detail today except
saying that the most work as well as the
work that we are going to I'm going to
talk about today a uses relatively small
and mostly very well defined domains and
there is this really interesting
challenge of how you can do broad
coverage parsing and we have a paper
about this
recently so what do I mean when I talk
about context and to illustrate this i'
would like to show you a very simple and
short example of our algorithms on a PR2
robot so on the top left here you see
the robot's point of view on the right
you see me teaching the robot a new
skill by using speech commands and by
man ating its arms so this is a
programing by demonstration scenario and
on the bottom left you see the
representation of what the robot is
learning and as you as you notice as as
I give the as you will notice as I give
the obos commands I don't specify
exactly what arm or gripper I'm
referring to but the robot is able to
disambiguate and understand in this case
that I mean closing the left hand cling
left and then the interaction continued
and I'll say close again again the robot
will try to disambiguate and in the next
case we'll see we'll understand Time
closing the right hand so what's
happening here is that the robot is
continuously tracking the state of the
world specifically what the agent is
manipulating and it uses this as
contextual information to disambiguate
the user's command so this is a very
simple example and the language here is
as simple as it gets but I'm showing
this to you because it really
illustrates how jointly reasoning about
the state of the world the action to
execute both things are both of these
things are the context and the language
itself leads to much better
communication
and but of course language is a much
more complicated and on contexts are
much richer and this is something that
TR is also and this is the problem that
TR also worked on before us H so in this
case we worked on interpreting
instructions like place your bank
against the wall of the T intersection
10 left and so forth and executing them
in in an environment where you have a
robot navigating in the Maze with a lot
of things that the instructions can
refer to and the challenging thing in
this scenario is that you really have to
take the and the state of the world and
what the agent observes into account to
be able to execute these instructions
accurately and and this actually allows
some very interesting interplay where
the state of the world determines how
the agent understands language language
understanding determines the the actions
that the agent performs and these in
turn actually specify the state of the
world okay so the second aspect I would
like to H briefly talk about is the
learning problem so a big challenge here
is learning with less supervision so our
goal in learning is to take sentences
paired with some sort of supervision we
have this Corpus of many sentences and
we like to earn this function that maps
from sentences to logical forms and the
but the challenge is that annotating
each and every decision the system has
to make is extremely labor intensive and
requires very specific expertise so the
first solution that people adopted is
okay let's not annotate all the decision
system has to make except instead let's
annotate only the final logical forms so
this really saves up saves up a lot of
the work but it's still relatively labor
intensive and creating these logical
forms is very requires specific
expertise so the kind of stuff that the
kind of approach that we have looked at
in in previous work is trying to ask
what kind of learning SC we can get from
Context and that can and we showed that
this allows you to learn from a very
easily gathered supervision and in some
cases without any annotation at all so
for example we can h look at a
conversation in this case between a
system and a travel planning between a
user and a travel planning system and
something that I would like to highlight
when we look at this conversation is how
systems can recover when after they fail
these kind of interactions so in this
kind of scenarios the user can make
requests such as from Boston on the 7th
of June with American Airlines and if
you ever try to give this kind of a
request to a system like Cortana for
example I have to use a local example
then you're going to get something like
I'm sorry Dave I didn't get all of it
flying to New York what theye would like
to depart Boston so the system
completely missed the date in the
carrier it did get the
origin so what this system can do next
it has a specific goal and it's
interacting with the user so it can
simply start asking for questions and
using very simple questions continue the
interaction creating a conversation that
is far from ideal but this kind of
recovery will allow it to continue but
also include a lot of information about
the user request that the system
initially fail to understand so what we
showed is that you can take this kind of
recovery and without any notation except
recording these conversations you can
learn to better understand the user
request learning to learning from
failures to avoid these kind of failures
in the future and in the long term in
incorporating this kind of learning
approach into a complete dialogue system
we allow these kind of systems to
continuously improve for interaction
with users so you have systems that
start with a relatively primitive
understanding of language and by talking
to users become better and better better
okay thank you very
much so just press
next
okay okay hello everyone I'm Percy um
I'm going to talk about execu natural
language this is a Python program and
it's nice because you can execute it and
you can get an answer and the way I
think about natural language is uh very
much the same way I think about natural
language is encoding some sort of
computation that we want to actually be
able to uh perform um so I'll give you
two examples of some of the tasks that
we've been looking at that fall under
this kind of General framework one is
question answering you're given a
question you g a table and you have to
kind of understand uh the computation
that's uh implicit in the question and
identify 2004 as an answer here's
another example which uh similar to what
yov talked about you're given a robot
instructions get the cup filled with
water and you want to map it to a
sequence of actions that actually gets
executed in the world um so you know
what I actually care about is the actual
execution but the way I'm going to solve
it is via uh semantic parsing where the
idea is that you map natural language
into logical forms and this breaks down
the process into two parts one is the
understanding uh and mapping the natural
language to The Logical form and the
second part is knowing the answer or
figuring out what the comp actually
performing the execution and what I'm
interested in doing is learning this um
pipeline where you actually don't see
The Logical forms so perhaps this is a
slight um you know slightly different
philosophy than um some of the other
talks where I only view the natural uh
The Logical forms as intermediate uh
representations for getting the test
done um so we developed some learning
algorithms this is kind of a just a toy
intuition for understanding what's going
on so learning algorithm doesn't know
anything it's going to start out with an
example of a question and an answer it's
going to generate possible candidate
logical forms execute them and see which
ones actually get the answer right often
there's kind of ambiguity so you go to
more examples and then over time you
gradually see kind of Statistics
emerging and then you might identify you
know the word to press means uh place of
death um so I'll list three uh kind of
open challenges uh for kind of working
in this framework the first one is the
fact that we're searching over the space
of programs is is very very large um and
this could take a while to actually get
so in some sense we're doing kind of um
program induction which we know to be
quite difficult so it's really like
finding a needle in a Hast stack and
we've developed some techniques to try
to address this the Second Challenge I
want to mention is um this uh what I
call highle Concepts um you might think
that who is Bill Gates grandmother is a
really easy question because all it
really means is you know Grand mother of
Bill Gates but actually when you're
mapping natural language to uh code um
The Primitives of the code are not often
uh aligned with the The Primitives and
the natural language in particular code
generally has lower level Primitives and
you need to be able to kind of induce
this whole structure gender female
parent parent and realize that this
means
grandmother and the third ex uh
challenge is been something that kind of
I think plagues us all which is uh kind
of the lack of data when you're talking
about relating natural language with
actual code and um the traditional way
that you go about doing this is well you
write down some examples of inputs U
maybe this is ad hoc and then you get
them annotated with a code and then you
can train whatever you want um so in
recent paper we actually uh found a
strategy that turned this uh story
around which was actually quite
effective so instead what we're going to
do is have a a grammar that is a grammar
really over programs so we're going to
generate a bunch of programs which are
kind of Representative of all the
perimeters that we're likely to see and
for each one of them we're going to
generate some half broken English that
um describes the semantics um but is not
really that fluent like person that is
author of the most number of Articles
and then we go to crowdsourcing and ask
them to paraphrase these into more
realistic utterances so you get nicer
things like who has published the most
articles and as a result you actually
get a nice data set of um examples of uh
questions and their logical
forms okay so one thing that um I guess
for this audience I'm quite interested
in is uh Smart Auto Complete in context
where um you might imagine you're
writing this function and you want to
say well geez this is Java I don't
remember how to open a file um because
it's Java so I'm going to you know type
in some keywords natural language and I
want to be able to map this onto the
code um in context so this is something
that we're starting to think about more
um so in summary I think um natural
language is uh I like to think about it
as actually com you know um encoding
some sort of computation that's been
done semantic parsing is kind of our
best way I think to actually get there
right now but I'm open to kind of other
types of representations and there's a
bunch of challenges and opportunities so
I'll conclude
there hi everybody hello yeah it's
working hi everybody my name is reinii
and I'm a second year PhD student at
udab uh my advisers are Luke zire and
Alvin ching and I think both of them
have been part of this Workshop so I am
mainly interested in uh how can we use
natural language to help uh users write
database queries and I think this is
really important because um unlike other
programming languages database queries
are written by a a whole bunch of people
who are not computer scientists like
lawyers um scientists and people in
business so that's why I'm interested in
this task so this particular talk is
about something that I've been working
on right now which is learning to
summarize code and here I'm talking
about summarizing uh database
queries um
so specifically I'm looking at database
queries which uh which can get fairly
complex like this and I'm trying to uh
um get a natural language description of
the query which is not extremely verbose
so we don't go into every column name
and table name uh but this would be
summarized using a sentence uh like this
which is like get the lowest K RS based
on a formula so this is important
because this would be helpful uh to
actually retrieve the right snippet of
code so this would actually help going
from language to code and it's also
useful for uh commenting database
queries and explaining database queries
for people writing them for the first
time so since we want to learn to do
this
automatically uh like okay um we're
using uh stack Overflow as our data set
and uh we're using all the queries uh
tagged with uh the SQL tag and um so
we're using the query from the accepted
answer in the post and uh we're
currently using the title of the stack
oflow post as a proxy for a summary of
the query and uh there are about 400,000
queries right now in stack so which are
actually Tagg the SQL which is very
good um currently we're only making use
of the select queries uh and uh here's a
distribution of tables columns functions
and subqueries in the queries that we're
using and as you can see we do have some
fairly complex queries with two or more
subqueries four to five functions and
many tables and
columns so uh so this is entirely
preliminary work uh we have some
baselines uh one of them is an
information Ral Baseline where we
finding the closest query in the
training set by abstracting over the
table table names and column
names uh and uh using the title
associated with that as a summary for
the query and uh we also compare with
phrase Bas translation using
Moses and uh the kind of models that we
using are uh these encoder decoder lsdm
models which have recently been
successfully used for empty tasks um by
S at Al at Google so the way these
models work is we're modeling the
conditional distribution of the next
word uh given the entire input and the
uh words produced so far so we treat the
um we treat the code as a sequence of
tokens and uh we generate a
distributional representation of the
entire input by passing it through an
encoder lstm block and uh the decoder
part of the model is a uh neural
language model which is conditioned on
the representation of the
input so even with uh this kind of model
um we have some pre preliminary
results uh we are going to do a human
evaluation eventually but right
now uh we just using Blue SC
and
uh um we we're already doing pretty well
uh as compared to the information R tal
methods I'm running out of time uh but
here are some of the predictions that
we're getting right now um and uh some
of them are fairly good but we're still
running into some uh
issues so um we're mainly going to
augment our models using two recent
ideas uh
one is uh the idea of tre lstms so um uh
since SQL is code uh we have several
tree representations of code and we can
generate a richer distributional
representation by composing over a tree
representation and for SQL we have the
SQL parity and the relational algebra
tree so uh the other idea that uh we're
looking into is this idea of neural
attention models so instead of
instead of compressing the entire input
into one uh distributional
representation uh we keep we keep
representations of all the tokens and in
the decoding phase we can decide which
representations are more important than
others so we use the soft alignment
model which
uh uh and we can also see a visual
representation of whether the model is
working or not because we get this soft
alignment so here uh it learns that
count in the output aligns with count in
the
input and uh this is our proposed model
where we uh generate a distributional
representation of the input code by
composing over uh the uh the SQL par and
uh we use an alignment model over the
entire uh par three so the model learns
to associate words in the output with
nodes in the uh part three of the
input and that's all I had thank
you there's no no
clicker right okay um hello everyone I'm
uh Nate kushman uh I was at MIT and I
will be at MSR but I'm technically
unemployed right now um
so um this is going to be a little
repetitive because I have the
disadvantage of going close to last and
not having seen anyone's slides before I
made
mine so um forgive me for that uh so my
goal is to enable lay users I guess like
a lot of other people to program and or
to write some form of program in natural
language um computers are part of
people's everyday life and as a result
uh lay users are now wanting more and
more to do comp comp complex and
specialized computational tasks and many
of these still require them to write
some form of sort of formal program um
and most of these users are not very
Adept at using formal languages but
they're quite Adept at using natural
language and there are many existing
resources written in natural language so
a traditional focus of semantic parsing
um sort of you know in sort of raise
perspective of this um more so than I
think a lot of the other talks you've
just seen which are much more sort of
the recent work um is formal languages
designed specifically for use with with
natural language so these include sort
of these abstract representations where
they're not necessarily connected to any
computational device underneath but
they're just trying to sort of generally
describe all possible things that
someone might say in a formal way so
this is AMR and prop bank and framenet
um then there's also more of this stuff
that I think we've seen here which is
these logical representations for
describing natural language um and these
are things like knowledge based schemas
or robotic languages but again we're
we're designing the schema itself or the
robotic language in a way that we know
that it's going to map nicely to natural
language and there's a key advantage of
that which is that we allow have this
close structural alignment between the
natural language and the and the formal
language so when we say um you know walk
until we get to some point we have some
you know uh representation or formal
language that says walk until you know
um and the disadvantage though of course
is that the representation just just
needs some linguistic expertise so we
can't these can't be designed by lay
users you need some either natural
language processing person or some
linguist to kind of come in and design
these things in a way that they know
it's going to map nicely to natural
language and there's very little
agreement on people Everyone is sort of
coming up with new representations for
new domains um and often these
representations are very domain specific
you know in some sense by necessity um
and as a result there's no data in the
wild so the alternative approach that I
sort of Taken um as well as you know a
lot of the work that we just saw is
mapping natural language directly to uh
existing program so they're sort of
trying to take off-the-shelf programming
languages or off-the-shelf systems that
have an API to them already and use that
as the formal representation rather than
something that we manually design to map
nicely to natural language um so some
examples of what I've done or take uh a
natural language description of a text
query and from that generate a regular
expression that we can actually execute
in order to perform that query or take a
natural language description of some
complicated math problem and generate
the system of equations which can be
solved in order to get the answer to
that problem or take some description
natural language description of a
virtual world and use that description
to help us learn how to generate you
know programs that will actually perform
a task in that
world so why these sort of existing pro
programs
so the main thing is that formal
languages already exist for these many
domains of Interest so people have gone
and painstakingly written down apis and
uh programming languages for all sorts
of things people care about I and we can
take advantage of these existing systems
and apis and secondly there's lots of
natural language resources for these
existing systems that we can also take
advantage of documentation help articles
and so on and so forth so we don't have
to necessarily generate this data um
it's already out there in the wild and
that's I think the biggest advantage of
working with these existing
systems um and so our goal you know as
such our goal here is to learn entirely
from data that's uh either readily
available or easily gathered I missed
this last point which is to say that
even if the data is not out there
already we can take advantage of users
who know how to use these systems in
order to generate the data for us so
there's a bunch of challenges that come
up when we are not allowed to design the
language specifically to map to natural
language and I'll talk about a couple of
the ones uh that I've tackled in in the
research I've done um so traditional
semantic parsing techniques sort of work
in this way where they rely on this
ability to decompose meaning so here's a
typical example from the geoc domain
that Ray talked about um and what you
can see is that what we're try what we
end up trying to do is map some chunk of
the natural language to some chunk of
the formal language and do this sort of
alignment type model um and this is sort
of the typical techniques are based on
this and they assume that something like
this is possible otherwise uh we can't
actually do it
correctly and so the challenge when
we're mapping to existing programming
languages and often times the training
data doesn't have this property um
because we're not allowed to design the
language to ensure that that property is
there so for example here's a natural
language description of a text query and
the result in regular
expression and if we try to find for
example something that maps to three
letter the best we can do is this chunk
here which is a followed by two letters
which obviously doesn't represent three
letter in general and similar for words
and starting with
a and so the Insight here is that we can
pull a tools from the software
engineering community which is that we
can determine the semantic equality
between seemingly different programs so
if the training data is not decomposable
like this example that we just saw here
then what we can do is find a
semantically equivalent
program which is decomposable for
example this regular expression here
where three letter maps of the first
chunk and words the che chunk and
starting with a the third
chunk so that's the second challenge is
that even when we have existing
resources we have existing a formal
language and existing natural language
we often don't have them in parallel out
there in the wild and so we need new
training data of this form in each
domain
and so the second Insight is that we can
execute some possible interpretation of
the resulting natural language and learn
directly from those results without any
labeled training data at all so consider
the domain uh the virtual world of
Minecraft which many of you may be
familiar with um here's a sentence I
pulled from the Minecraft Wiki cooked
fish is obtained when raw fish is cooked
in a furnace so maybe that means that in
order to get raw fish I need to First
have cook fish or maybe it means in
order to have uh fish I need to First
have raw fish but I don't know which is
the right interpretation of that but if
I give this first thing as a constraint
to some underlying planner and then ask
it to perform uh some task of gener of
of producing raw fish
say then it's going to fail to find that
plan find a plan correctly and
secondarily if I give this constraint uh
to the underlying planner uh in
performing some task and the planner is
going to actually succeed and we can use
this signal uh to interpret text VI via
some form of reinforcement learning um
and finally I just want to say going
forward I'm particularly interested uh
in probabilistically modeling the domain
using unlabeled data so utilizing these
existing huge open source repositories
in order to correctly learn to correctly
interpret ambiguous uh or under
specified natural language by sort of
filling it in with well what do people
usually mean you know what does a common
program do uh in this in this particular
case so that's it for me and I guess
there's one more person right UA is up
okay
I have a web browser
oh
so I'll um I'll start with an demo
because my slides is of pool quality I
think the slides are ordered descendant
by quality um right so here um this is
what we want to do so we want to enable
programmers to write a query in ide in
this particular case read fire line by
line where you can specify the location
of the fire variable through a par
through a variable um pth and we
actually suggest a code where um you can
read the file line by line actually
where is the variable correctly placed
in the right um uh context now um this
is information reeval um see this um
little link here saying that is coming
from sa flow so we basically achieve and
piece of code and try to adapt it to the
users's context um now we want to do
this from scratch we want to generate
the code from scratch given the query
given a very fuzzy query I'm not sure
why we need to do this but somehow it
fascinates me
okay so let me switch back to the
presentation here um we want to look at
a problem from a statistical translation
point of view but when we trying to do
that we realize this is a scenario of a
question answering the problem here the
challenge here is that
the the challenge is that um from smt
point of view the source and the target
are roughly one to one but this is not
the case for question answering you have
a large gap um between what you have in
the query and what you will suggest in
the solution so um if you think about
the
smt
um skeleton Bas equation equation you
have a likelihood function and you have
have a prior for the for language model
so in this answering case when you
happen to have the opportunity to look
at all the queries that people ask
through a search engine they're crazy
and you realize that you cannot actually
extract a lot of stuff from the query
itself themselves so you will have a
fairly weak um likelihood function so in
order to design those systems you have
to have a very strong prior that's what
that's why we are focusing on API
related um queries because apis are very
predictable each API type may have 5 10
kind of popular W ways of writing so and
this is this can be learned with various
techniques that um abandon from
literatures and that's what we did so um
we relax the
requirement to the natural language
understanding what we want to do is just
to get the API names a couple of API
names from the natural language that's
it and what we did is that we leverage
on a search engines click through data
there is an R missing here it's click
through um click through records where
what Pro what people type in the search
bar and what page they actually um click
on and if we look at the web pages
themselves and extract all the code
there and trying to figure out what are
the API names we can build this big big
reference table from
um the phrases or the words from from
user queries to the API names we
actually used um the simple IBM model
one to build this um currence table and
for API patterns we
um learned all these patterns using
um
vanilla mining Technique we learned
those patterns from GitHub now the
generating the code generation part is
straight forward meaning that we have we
need to start from a query figure out a
couple of POS most likely apis and go to
go to our um patent library to figure
out what are the most likely patterns
and then try to combine them together so
this is the code that we generate from
the query match regular expression and
this this is exactly the code no
character more no character less
actually it contains two patterns
because the um IBM model one tell us the
most um likely apis are um r x and match
so this these are two patterns moving
together one is one starts from the
creation of regx object and then ends at
calling match here and the second one is
for match so the match is created
implicitly by the match invocation and
there is
a
um if condition saying if the match is
successful we get actually some data
from the match the part now um so the
synthesiz it actually
just weave those two patterns together
of course there's something more to
handle for example order
um all the variable names needs to be
um in the right form so these are just
calculated by looking at what's the most
popular
um variable names for this particular
API operant and all these things are
done independent ly so they may look
weird when you look at large piece of
code but that's what we are right now
thank you very
much okay yeah so I guess now it's just
open to to General discussion either
from the speakers or the or the general
audience uh Chris and I just compiled a
sort of very uh summarized set of uh
topics that uh we might uh discuss
number of them came up one I like is the
dialogue I like the idea of using these
external sources of knowledge like the
APA manuals IP API man that's really not
on our uh list discourse came up where I
mean sort of conversation where you're
not going to get it the first shot
you're going to have to have a
discussion with the user to sort of
refine the program in natural language
rather than just get it the first shot
um another one I put the end that didn't
come up but at least I know I've had
discussions with Nate about this is is
not just doing language alone but
combining it with sort of program
synthesis from IO tupal input output
pairs or by programming by demonstration
I know your regex work does this right
it does a it does a natural language
sentence plus a couple of examples of
what you want the regex to match or not
match right so I think that's another
interesting uh issue that didn't really
come up in the talks I
think but anyway I think it's open yeah
so somebody U mentioned blue as a way of
evaluating the result of the output and
there's need some criticism in this
after Comm about using blue because you
know is using blue one Tok being might
be arbitrarily horrible yeah you know
program yeah everybody hates blue even
in I always say these things are like
what uh Winston Churchill said about
democracy I assume people know this it's
the worst possible Farm of government
except for all the others yeah no but we
we have exactly this problem it's just
that I haven't seen anything better out
there and it's often times really
expensive metor sometimes used but
anyway I mean may it may they may be
Epsilon better but don't see them being
a Quant Quantum leak better and human
evaluation is often very expensive so I
think there is no substitute for human
evaluation but also the I I can't
emphasize enough the impact that an a
quick automatic evaluation metric made
on the progress of the machine
translation field because before that we
were gated by just producing results and
running them by humans and so the read
Val print Loop like that development
cycle was just so slow having even an
imperfect um automated evaluation me
made the field really take off over the
past evaluation metrics but that's
really relevant to the code to language
part I don't think anyone would propose
using BL for doing evaluation of
language to code is anyone I don't think
it has been done I mean other it's bad
enough for natural language but doing it
for programs is because it wasn't that's
something it even wasn't even designed
for you could compile it you could type
check
it yeah well what Chris and I did we try
because our thing was so simple it's
just like if there's like a a so-called
channel on the if side a channel on that
and then they have arguments we sort of
broke it down into accuracy of the
different pieces because the structure
was sort of fixed but I mean I think it
is that's why we put it on this list is
how do you really evaluate how do you
know whether I mean it's just the idea
of program correctness in the end of the
day is this really the right program for
this natural language and how do we have
even if we have a gold standard program
that someone has annotated a corpus with
now we have program equivalence which we
all know is like undecidable in the
general case right so yeah I mean
it's definitely an issue is what is the
right evaluation I think we can all
agree blur on comparing two programs
with blur you know God can I can I
disagree real quick because I thought
about this a little bit um so there was
a talk about idiomatic code right so I
think compiling and running won't tell
if it's idiomatic or not I'd be
interested in ideas about ways to do
that without using something like blue
for examp so I mean we've sort of been
looking at like two levels of this the
first level is did you get the desired
answer
so I mean in the work that I've been
doing on this and the work with Sumit
and all this there are two levels one is
do you get the right answer and that's
sort of the first key question if you
don't get that then it doesn't quite
matter what you produce and that's easy
to check I mean in many cases you had
training data you had desired output you
compile the program you run it if the
answer is match you're great right then
the second is this notion of idiomatic
and I think that is a much fuzzier
question where you have to sort of say
well how close was this program to the
reference gold standard and you know how
strictly do you want to measure that and
I don't have any deep experience with
that sort of textual comparison so
answers like a database query this is
what I've always done and what people in
sematic parsing do for database queries
you can compare the answer output but
that doesn't always work for all
programs I mean there are programs that
are complicated you know sort a list
well sure you can compare for a certain
set of inputs but again it's it's a
program verification question at the end
of the day whether that's do sorting an
arbitrary
list I mean just to make the problem
even more complicated I think that
um even you know evaluating whether the
program is the same as the correct
program is not good enough because a lot
of times when you give a natural
language specification you only care
about some limited set of inputs sort of
implicitly and so actually you only care
that you get the right answer on that
limited set of inputs and there's
actually multiple different sort of
formally semantically different programs
that are really correct in terms of what
the natural language is saying in terms
of the intent of the user rather than um
rather than sort of what the gold
program actually does
so so this is going to tie back to
evaluation but um I guess one thing that
seems maybe a little bit um not ideal is
that I guess the domain specificity when
you actually kind of work with semantic
parsing you know we have things that do
database queries we have things that
control robots and regular expressions
and it seems kind of still you know a
lot of the techniques are kind of shared
but it seems you know still a bit uh
fragmented and this is kind of in
contrast with um you know broad coverage
uh sematic representations which don't
give you exactly PR you know the precise
meaning or exe anything executable but
at least it has kind of broad coverage
um and so I guess to connect up with the
software engineering it seems like um in
software engineering because you're
dealing with such large code bases um
you're kind of basically in the broad
coverage domain as opposed to for
example if you're maybe more in the
doing PL and on like you're TR to
synthesize like a 10line program that
you can actually have a spec for and
verify so so I guess um I'm trying to
think about you know I I see this kind
of parallel between you know broad
coverage uh things like AMR and you know
narrow coverage like uh the sematic
parsing work and then over on the
program language side you have broad
coverage let's just retrieve code versus
like let's synthesize or verify like a
very small uh piece of code and kind of
we're trying to move diagonally or try
to kind of connect up and I guess
relating to evaluation um it seems like
when you're in the broad coverage
setting you just can't really have any
sorts of precise evaluation and it has
to either be something fuzzy like blue
or um ultimately I guess blue or um you
know some sort of precision recall or
ultimately hopefully you know some sort
of human evaluation but I just wanted to
kind of laay out uh that one thing I
wonder I some assume some of our
software engineering folks have no idea
what this blow thing is I mean it just
looks at you know sequences of end
tokens and figures out how many of them
you got right basically so it's a very
surface level evaluation I'm just make
trying to be cognizant here that we're
don't all speak the same
language um so I'm um trying to
understand a difference I see between
the discussion earlier today and and the
and a lot of the examples we saw here so
earlier we said like software
requirements are these really open-ended
natural language documents and uh
somehow they relate to code but the
distance is so far that that we're not
quite sure what we can do but then I saw
a number of examples here that kind of
look more tractable so you've got the
internet of things you've got your home
alarm system in general you have some
kind of an action language or a uh an AI
planning language or something like that
where you can construct program
sequences of actions and then you have
utterances and you're trying to uh
figure out well did is the utterance
ambiguous well what could they have
meant and it looks like there's a lot of
hope that you could actually do a lot
really you know in the short run in the
next five years I mean can somebody who
knows more than I do like comment on
what you think's possible and um you
know sort of what are the limitations
or
waxe on that topic I mean I think that
um uh you know my perspective on this is
that I think it's all a matter of you
know how close the alignment is and how
much data you have the more data you
have the more you can sort of learn
patterns from it and and make bigger
leaps um and the the um the bigger the
leaps that you you know have have to
make in terms of the difference between
sort of literally what you're saying in
the natural language and what you're
seeing in the code um you know and I
think that you know there's a lot of
opportunity for sort of cross doain
stuff here where we have um a very small
amount of data Maybe in some domain but
we have a lot of data kind of across a
wide variety of domains to try to learn
from that um to to get the the amount of
data we need but I think that's sort of
where we're at now is sort of we've got
this sort of little transation things
kind of working and now we want to go up
maybe one level of abstraction um and
you know in the question
yeah so I wonder if you know if you look
at the like AI planning language or or
whatever and then you you let it get
more complex like you allow concurrency
or you can think about data races and
things like that then suddenly your
natural language has like that
complexity to deal with is this an
Avenue like um for Nate or anyone you
know where where you say you know I now
I'm starting to understand why this is
hard and this is a problem that we need
to work
on
I can't say something else wants
to no I mean I think that a lot of I
mean I think there's sort of two two
complexities and they're not the ones
that are hard for natural language and
the ones that are hard from the software
side are not they're not always
correlated um and I think that you know
things like you know concurrency and
stuff like that are things that in some
sense it's like well let's assume you
knew exactly what the human wanted could
you make it work the way that they
wanted it right and so the figuring out
what the human wanted is one part and
then figuring out how to make it work
that's where we hope the software
engineering people come in with all
their tools to kind of do magic and make
the concurrency and make it work the way
I would want it to work even though I
don't understand as the user I don't
understand all of that interaction and
all of what is required in order to make
it work but you you're still presenting
me this interface that I as a sort of
nonconcurrency understanding user can
work with um so that's sort of I mean in
the same way that say a highle
programming language would do that for
or you know or something like map reduce
does for you know complex quers or
whatever you want to provide an
interface of that form and then do all
the programming magic underneath um and
and that's separate from the question of
how do I get from natural language to
something that I can even work with so I
you know I don't I'm not clear that
those two problems are exactly
correlated
something so so when I came here Chris
and I had a long discussion about what
we what exactly wanted to do and I think
it's this tradeoff that Nate was talking
about you need a programming language
that at least is interesting enough to
be you know complex enough to be
interesting but yet something we could
get a lot of data for which is why we
landed on this if they're not very
complicated programs and we could get a
lot of data from it by just scraping it
off the web and so that's why we landed
on doing that but it's definite that you
know we can only do this for Fairly you
know limited complexity programs with a
fair bit of data at this point and I
think we could push both of those you
know push the learning ideas because
there's been a lot of work in the
database query like Percy's stuff and
things that Luke's grp donees reducing
the amount of supervision we need to do
that so decreasing the data demands on
the one hand and then increasing the
complexity of what we can handle uh uh
on the other and I there's lots of you
know way ways we need to improve this in
both of those Dimensions I think I me
there is this kind of uh vision of maybe
I'm speaking loudly enough but um so so
like so in the you know there's this uh
area called enduser programming where
people who use spreadsheets suddenly uh
they're 50 million extra programmers who
can make errors and need to test and all
of that and now with the Internet of
Things sort of you know area everything
is trickling down so you're going to
just have massive numbers of people
writing very small programs Facebook
users at least I Chris and I most of us
I think in this community believe that's
where we're trying to focus is this
simple little programs that end users
want to write we really think that's the
sweet spot for natural language
programming we're not going to you know
program Boeing's control of a 747 using
natural language but if then if this
then that is actually handle that and so
we're trying to push it's like
H sorry Abraham first I
think uh so there's this area in
software engineering called Model driven
software development and to the end user
it often times looks like drag and
dropping boxes and arrows and it's used
to generate usually domain specific
programs so in a lot of cases you might
be able to amp up the at least level of
the user who wants the program just by
having a domain specific kind of model
that you do generate too now the thing
with model driven development is you've
actually dropped out a lot of the
language stuff in this process you've
turned it into more of like a a graph
connection problem but it feels sort of
similar but I just know that quite a few
people are probably unaware of model
driven
development thanks um so I'm really
interested to see a bullet point up
there that says enduser debugging um
that seems really hard to me so I wonder
if the person who added it has more
insight um or anyone else okay so I I
totally have to credit Ben zor for this
Insight like yeah so I I paid attention
to some of the early work that Mark Mark
Marin here and mwani did with um trying
to build programs and Excel
automatically through demonstration I
think that stuff is beautiful work um
but sometimes it comes up with a wrong
program and what do we do right like I
think they've done some good work in
trying to surface like maybe what are
some outlier programs maybe naturalness
has something to play here but like as
soon as we start building a formalism we
need to represent that back to the user
we need to push back somehow I don't
know how to do this I just know that
it's gonna be a problem because like I
spend way too much time debugging my
programs you know I can't and I know the
computer pretty well I
think so again I'll I'll wax qu on this
if no one else wants to um so I think
there's two two interesting ideas to to
follow on that right so first is is the
generation side so let's say I yes sure
I some I you say something I generate a
program and then I sort of regenerate a
canonical meaning of that in natural
language is maybe overly verbose you
know but that gives you some sense maybe
a better sense of of how I interpreted
what you meant in a way that an end user
understand and I think the second thing
is is this you know input output
examples you know just sort of you know
it doesn't do what you want you say you
know what what what you know where where
is it not doing what you want you know
and you give it some example of where
it's broken and then it tries to find
another you know so it's sort of you
know combining natural language with
input output examples in terms of trying
to do the auggy right so the first one
is like analogist to this thing where
you translate to the foreign language
and back yeah just to get a feel for
what what is it even doing let's assume
I'm not a program so I can't understand
the formal program but I want to
understand what that PR conect to the
topic of the next session which is going
the other way which and the two are
clearly linked I don't I think we only
put them in two separate sessions so it
was sort of the obvious way but there's
clear connections between going one way
and the
other there's a couple Mark you is that
okay Mark go
first yeah so I just wanted to add in I
think in in a lot of cases you see
domains where I mean we saw this a lot
in the sort of natural language to Excel
formula like people know what they want
to do in Excel they have some idea of
what the programming language is but the
exact syntax the exact way they put the
arguments they just don't remember right
and so even if you can show them a
reasonable looking program they can look
at that and say okay yeah you know I
wrote this in natural language I said
sum the column you know two where the
value is Ohio they look at the formula
it says sum it says something about
colum 2 it says something about Ohio
they're confident that you you know
reinterpreted their intent correctly so
even though they aren't expert
programmers they understand enough about
the do domain language they understand
more or less how it should work and they
can sort of verify that they're happy
with that so I think there's sort of you
know a lot of options there there's that
there's the paraphrase to natural
language and of course you know saying
oh let me run some examples here's one
that's sort of ambiguous in the programs
I found which is the right answer you
know there are a lot of modalities that
you can use depending on the complexity
of the domain the expertise of the users
some are more valuable than others so I
think it's really important to consider
the overall user experience in these
tools and not just say oh there's sort
of a one siiz fits all or there's an
optimal right it's very sort of
subjective across what you're trying to
do and there are several good options
maybe I should just interject for a
second because sorry like this a little
bit self- serving but uh I one of the
things that I tried to build for an
early version of there's this Flash Fill
functionality that Sumit and and you did
you work on didn't do this this is
actually reshop so correct that that
wasn't I can't take credit for can like
start you can have an imperfect column
and you start typing correct examples of
what should be in that column to the
right of it and it infers a program and
prints that out so I I made some
prototype that did exactly what Nate did
that said like here's a really templatic
restatement of what that program does
and it totally got cut because everybody
hated
it so I I I think this is a great area
there's a lot of interesting HCI
challenges as much as anything else so
yeah thanks um so yeah so I just as far
as like uh the focus on the enduser I
just want to say even you know non
beginning programmers or non-programmers
have huge problems because like
essentially you're dealing as a
programmer with very large information
spaces apis are enormous and complex um
you know so um uh you know possible
fixes are enormous and complex so you
know then and there's huge amounts of
data so you can build good priors so um
so you know so in this setting you know
maybe in addition to helping beginners
you can also help experienced
programmers you know think of it as an
information retrieval no that's why
definitely why we put that bullet up
there is there's a range and I think
most the work is focused on in users but
I think I know Chris and I agree that
there are other applications for more
advanced programmers all along the
Spectrum I think that's why you put this
power user up there which I guess is
sort of what the this the this the what
you were talking about Mark is it's some
they know sort of know the language but
they're not very good right and I think
there's this is useful at all levels I
think most of the work is focused on let
me say one of the thing I think a lot of
cases is stuff
okay so for those of you who have
written okay the Excel formula language
is awful right it's just horrible to
remember it's horrible to figure out
being recorded yes okay I'm I'm sorry to
whoever said that yes um and and so yeah
so we've had some I mean user studies
where people say you know we showed them
sort of the natural language part and
they said well this is I mean they knew
how to write Excel formula right they
spent all day in Excel they could do
this no problem but this was just faster
and easier for them than trying to sort
of switch out of there I'm analyzing
this data I want to answer a question
now I need to think about writing the
Excel formula I think regular
expressions are another great example
right I need to sit stop thinking about
what I'm trying to do and think about
the funny semantics of a regular
expression so if they can say what they
want sort of free form in natural
language they're able to stay sort of
mentally connected to their task flow
and avoid this task switch and that was
a great benefit for them even if they
were technically capable of doing the
task you know on their own so it was a
little bit of an inside sorry
I to make
mic so I think it might be useful to
draw a distinction between kind of
programs and uh program output is kind
of what two things that the user might
want so in the first case um your goal
is actually produce a program and this
is useful when you kind of want to
execute it over and over again or you're
not executing it now like you know if
then is a good example um if you have a
Excel you know formula you might want to
change the data and have the same thing
work um and in but in a lot of cases in
end user programming you have some data
you just want to clean up this data and
you just it's totally oneof and um there
you know programs might be the way to do
it but also you might imagine some sort
of you know other statistical procedure
that just cleans it up and then you're
done um so I guess I I think there's
kind of interesting tradeoffs um you
know when you're you know forcing
yourself to Output a program that means
you kind of fall victim to all the kind
of the the rigidities of your underlying
Primitives I just you know one example I
remember like when Facebook Graph Search
you know came out and you typed like you
know people who my friends who like
pizza or something it's like maps to the
set of people who have clicked like on
Pizza um which is not what you want so
often there's kind of a it's harder to
uh bridge the gap between your user
intent and The Primitives um that the
API supplies whereas if you're for
example you know doing this in a oneoff
setting then you can actually have much
more at your uh disposable disposal um
on the other hand you know the oneoff
thing might be kind of hard to
interpret I think I mean just to add on
that I mean I think there's it's I
actually think it's a spectrum because I
think when whenever you know one one end
of the spectrum is I'm running the
program on one input like this one
database or this one cont you know one
file and I want it to work the other end
of the spectrum is I want it to work
unambiguously for all possible inputs
but a more common scenario I think is I
I have some domain specific input in
mind um you know even in the case of
regular Expressions I have some certain
file format in mind and I want to write
a regular expression that works on this
file format not just on one file but on
all files of this format but it's still
quite a constraint domain so there's
sort of a there's a lot of this question
of how to think about context in the
natural language um and how how much you
can take that context into account and
what exactly you know you know the one
end is I have exactly one context but in
the middle is I think quite common as
well actually I just uh from that
comment I thought of an interesting
thing where you actually are given the
input and have to create the program
based on the input and the natural
language so that's what I was trying to
refer to in that last oh okay done that
sort of stuff okay cool yeah and and and
and and and goting and Market done oh
yeah I guess you thought about that a
little bit but like you have a a thing
where you have com columns that are
separated with tabs or they're separated
with uh bars or something like that or
commas uh so you have a text file and
you say I want uh the First Column
uppercase or something like that and the
First Column will depend on whether it's
a tab uh whether the columns are
separated by tabs separated by commas
separated by uh whatever so yeah you're
you're saying that the distribution of
the input data actually affects the
program affects the program itself yeah
yeah yeah I mean there's this whole area
by programming by demonstration right
that I put up there that I don't know if
I've seen so much working on integrating
natural language instruction with that I
guess firsty was I'm sorry
uh who was uh yeah yoah was talking
something about that like with the
robot Daniel gildia had one paper on
that and I don't
know but yeah I mean I think we're all
agreeing that just the natural language
by itself is probably not going to be at
least one off is not going to be
sufficient you need to talk to the user
and say what did you mean by this you
need to have a dialogue maybe you put in
some IO tuples maybe they demonstrate
exactly the process they want to happen
on a toy example I think there's a lot
of different ways of providing input to
help you disambiguate because like Chris
said with this if there's a lot of these
things are very short you know you saw
he put some of the examples there's no
way you can get the whole program out of
that little short little description
that the person wrote you're going to
have to engage and some other
interaction with the user to clarify
their intent
and so there's a question for this
software enging Community when
sorry when when you have uh uh you know
specifications or programs do you often
have input examples as well or is that
just not part of the process when you
have any kind of sort of natural
language resources that you're you're
working with um are input examples
common or is that something that you
would then have to go hand generate
specifically for this purpose um well if
you do the if you do the EJ uh test
driven development for example you will
have very concrete test cases developed
before you write code so in that case
the input will be
available so so one thing because I I I
deal with a lot of the users being as we
actually build systems for any users at
IBM so we and I'll wait till I get the
mic here thanks CHR so we can go through
and we can build you you know test cases
and everything like that and we do and
one of the challenges is and then we
actually we build those initially with
developers and then uh when we're
talking about NLP systems that we
actually go and redeploy we build those
by crowdsourcing them typically starting
the company and then with f family and
friends about the interactions and then
inevitably the first day that we go
through through and switch these systems
live like the users are just talking a
completely different language like
inevitably it's it's no matter how much
we think we know what we're doing it's
not there
so it's it's a huge problem because um
the people building the system and the
people specking out the system are not
the end user of the system and the end
users are crazy this isn't being
recorded is it
sorry I see why they have two mic
Runners so this is something related to
that uh um and also more from the
software engineering persp perspective I
think the closest work in our field that
deals with this has to do with code
example search and system search I mean
Software System search so um we're not
like building the programs from scratch
but we're finding examples that are out
there and sometimes the uh the people
that search for these are end users that
don't necessarily know how to program
very well and they're looking for
something that already does the job for
them and also there's some uh work on
uh like searching uh for code examples
and searching for functions that based
on input output pairs so you don't write
a query in natural language but you give
an out input and an output so you give
in but you need to give enough examples
of that to be able to determine what
would be a a function that would be able
to give you that output now I think that
may be a combination of like a
specification natural language and input
output examples would be maybe a better
way to narrow down the search and find
something that's really useful for the
user and I'm wondering like maybe even a
combination of you know uh getting
programs uh from from scratch or like
generating the the programs and
searching for code examples maybe that
would be something to look into like an
intersection of the work that's been
done in the two
fields
so yeah I mean so one of the baselines I
think was on your chart that Chris and I
did was just Code retrieval we basically
just retrieve the closest program we
thought from the database that actually
doesn't do too bad right Chris it it is
a not it's a non-trivial baseline to to
beat the other thing I was just thinking
on this providing examples rather than
just the user providing them I've done a
lot of work on Active Learning I think
it be you understand the natural
language and then you ask the user hey
did you want this output for this input
and you could construct good input
output preps to ask the user to query to
help you disambiguate their intent I
hadn't actually thought of that Twist on
it but I think that would be a very
interesting twist I assume people who've
worked on this sort of thing would have
yeah Nate's not in his
head I guess maybe I could open a
question about sort of intermediate
representations versus final
representations like one thing for for
us who've been working in NL for a while
it's kind of attractive to have um an
output that's a concrete usable output
that means something to somebody you
know as opposed to something intrinsic
that we designed because we thought it
might be useful um uh or maybe maybe
that's just my own bias I should be
careful about putting words in the mouth
of other people um but on like so for
instance mapping directly like Nate is
talking about mapping directly from
language to executable code like I'm
really sympathetic to that because we
know we're solving an end problem we're
not solving some intermediate problem
that may or may not have an impact on
the final solution but it feels like
that's often times really really
difficult and so talking about like
formal specifications and requirements
being having some representation
language for those that was reusable
that we could map to I mean being able
to reify some of these Concepts into
real languages that people might
construct and that we could build that
could be cool except we we need to agree
on it and build consensus so we're
actually building a reusable Resource as
opposed to like lots of little one-off
Islands um I don't know are there any
thoughts about this I see Luke raising
his hand I should have been a little
slower because you kind of said a lot of
what I wanted to say in the second half
I Rose my hand too quickly but uh you
know having done a lot of this sort of
semantic parsing kind of work in my uh
research you know it's I really enjoy it
it's really great you can build really
cool systems but it's you know
incredibly frustrating I think Percy or
somebody else said this earlier that you
basically have to relearn from scratch
for each new thing you want to do right
and so this is one place where this
shows up so if you want to you know
build some very custom representation
for this particular task then you just
are going to have to gather data and
you're going to have to relearn from
scratch and you know one open challenge
is general purpose semantic tools so you
know all the people building ontologies
in this room I would love to give them
an
NLP thing call it a parser call it a
semantic analyzer whatever that would
take any text as input and provide them
something useful it's not going to solve
the whole problem but they're be much
better off than if they just started
writing regular Expressions over part of
speech I don't know what that thing
should look like but you know there's
not a huge amount of work at that more
semantic level in NLP on this and I
think there really needs to be a lot
more
I beat you by a few seconds it's like
theard okay so I think I I wanted to
make a couple statements on this from
sort of like a very PL perspective like
I don't care about what Intermediate
Language you learn to as long as it has
formal semantics because then I can
cross compile to any programming
language or runtime or whatever you like
right I mean that's a that's a solved
simple problem so from that standpoint
having a custom Intermediate Language
that makes the learning simpler that
seems like a better place to sort of
optimize the complexity Gap than the
actual target language um that said I'm
very sympathetic to this idea of and we
see this in program synthesis as well
you know there's a syn you know string
synthesizer or something else all these
small languages and the problem is you
have all these islands where you can do
individual tasks but really somebody
wants to do some larger task so this is
where I think it's very interesting to
start asking um and this goes back to
sort of the um compositional of semantic
parsing right I want to learn something
that talks about how I combine logical
predicates and I want to map to that
then I want to be able to you know take
that part of the sentence in isolation
translate it to a larger predicate now
that predicate could be part of a
database query it could be part of an if
then that query but I should be able to
translate this predicate in isolation
and then I should be able to substitute
it into this larger system that knows
about you know if then responses or I
should be able to substitute it into
something that knows about database
queries or I should be able to
substitute it into something that knows
about Airline queries so I think there's
a real question of can I do this
translation on individual domains of
interest and then have some sort of
generalized API so you can imagine Comm
right this is a way for arbitrary
software components that know nothing
about the semantics or the natural
language of another component to
communicate uniformly right is there
some sort of interface you can build
that allows you to say I have a domain
that knows about strings I have a domain
that knows about um conditionals I have
a domain that knows about travel I have
a domain that knows about places and
restaurant recommendations I don't need
to cross train on any of these domains
yet they can all communicate across key
parts of their information so that they
can be composed uniformly even though
they're all internally speaking
different languages I mean I think
that's a sort of an open interesting
question that I have that I wanted to
understand more and I don't have any
good answers to but that's sort of an
alternative to this is there an Uber
Lang language that everybody uses uh
problem so with that
I'll um so just as far as an application
of semantic parsing I don't think this
was mentioned um so earlier on there was
a debate about like the uses of
languages like Eiffel and how if
programmers would adopt the virtue of
putting in assertions and and
specifications in their code you know
everything would be so much better we
could verify programs we could you know
have better testing and whatever so you
know maybe this is another application
for semantic parsing is that if there a
way to programmers could more naturally
specify assertions um and there could be
semantic pareless which would sort of
insert that assertion into the chord
just make it easy for WR programmers to
write
assertions you know so it would be you
know maybe they they' give you more
assertions if if that was was made more
convenient just another possible
application for sematic
foring we're run tight on time I know
Jong was going to ask a
question yeah just a very quick comment
to what Mark said right there's this
language W from
language I think has position to be the
universal language right to has a lot of
like knowledges about various domains so
I think there's a 7 Minutes video that
he
has and
then per and then maybe we'll cut
off related to what PR has just said I I
we've done non studies a couple of ago
of um contracts in API documentation and
we we extracted like I don't remember
exactly but more than 500 or maybe 1,000
contracts uh in natural language in the
API Dock and I guess that most of them
are have their uh counterparts in the
code as as guards at the beginning of
the of the method body and or something
this so I think this might be an
interesting data set to learn the the
relation between the contract in the API
duck and and and the the precondition in
the code itself so add it to the data
set
website I have the code I have the and
and I have the for the
contracts are you going to tie it
together for person I'm going to tie
some subset of things together so I want
to go back to I guess uh maybe you and
Luke's comment about and um about I
guess the need for some sort of General
kind of
uh representation I think there's
actually two types of representation I
mean there's on the natural language
side there's basically representations
like uh um AMR for example that can
really tell you kind of the sentence
structure and what arguments go to what
um you know functions um but then as
we've seen there's actually kind of a
big disconnect between um the natural
language and you know the the tar Target
domain um not because you're actually
being maybe domain specific but just
because um of the you know way natural
language and U the structure of natural
language and formal languages are so I
wonder on the the formal languages side
it seems like independent of natural
language maybe there should be some sort
of uh unifying um principle and I guess
maybe the closest thing I can think
about is you know having some sort of
declarative um I don't want to say l or
um data log or sort of I don't know SQL
maybe maybe this reflects my kind of
database query biases but um but for for
example think about regular Expressions
right I mean a lot of the things you can
actually represent and you know
logically as well you know words that
contain a well contains just kind of a
binary predicate between a string and a
string and so maybe you can actually
have representations that just from a
pure program language point of view that
works on just kind of relation
and objects which then gets compiled
down into whatever the target language
is um I think this may becomes trickier
when you have maybe things which are not
so
declarative um but um so I mean I don't
know if people have any comments on on
the programming side if there's any kind
of uh things that can tie all the
different domains together I think um
our time at the workshop is a zero sum
game so I think answers to Percy's
questions we'll have to do that during
the closing session um because we should
get lunch we were going to get started
for the next session at 1:15 uh so that
means we have just shy of an hour I was
going to try to take you all to the same
place that we went to yesterday um so we
should get moving I think um so thanks
to all the speakers and to everybody for
a really
grateful